look for them to air in the near future
on book tv on c-span 2.
and now book tv's monthly in-depth
program with author and journalist matt
taibi mr taibi a contributor at rolling
stone magazine is the author of seven
books including the great derangement
griftopia and his most recent insane
clown president dispatches from the 2016
circus
matt taibi
in your most recent book insane clown
president
you write about president trump
quote he's no ordinary con man he's way
above average and the american political
system is his easiest mark ever
yeah well this was uh that was early in
the campaign i think that was um
i think that was in march of 2016. so it
was just around the time when he was
sewing up the republican nomination and
uh
the purpose of that article
because this is a compilation of
articles this book
was sort of to try
to explain the trump phenomenon to
people who were
for the first time having to take it
seriously and having to try to
come to grips with the fact that this
was happening um and so you know i i
took a kind of a different approach to
trump and and tried to really listen to
what his supporters were saying and try
to focus on what he was doing
and you know
my take on him was that he was
a brilliant media manipulator and that
he
was perfectly suited to
play on all the weaknesses of the
american political media and and that
turned out to be true um i wish i had
stuck to my guns in that piece because i
thought that he was going to be
president there and then and then later
on in the book i you know i didn't
believe that so well the day after the
election you wrote
i did not see donald trump coming right
everybody wrote that though didn't they
well they did yeah yeah i mean it's
funny i i i did see a long time ago that
we were going to have a problem with um
this sort of post-factual uh
media atmosphere and that were
for which trump was perfectly suited i
even wrote a book about it a long time
ago called the great derangement um but
i never saw donald trump specifically i
mean he was a unique
character and i think what was unique
about him was
he his insight was that the american
presidential election was basically just
a big reality show but it was a bad
reality show with bad with bad
characters and he made it an engrossing
impossible to miss reality show and he
was perfectly suited for the medium
well
along that line you write that donald
trump's innovation was to recognize what
a bad tv show the campaign was any
program that tried to make stars out of
human sedatives like scott walker and
lindsey graham needed new producers and
a new script exactly yeah and and
we had for a long time in the media uh
been drifting away from
substantive policy reporting uh and we
had more and more played up the
storytelling aspect the the production
values aspect of it um you know the
pageantry
the debates they were they were covered
like sports contests uh we had pregame
shows where people you know sort of
prognosticated who was going to win you
know we had these amazing graphics with
the dial surveys showing you know how
the person was doing according to what
he or she was saying
um
and trump
sort of looked at that format and he
said i think internally he said wouldn't
it be amazing if you put like a
professional reality actor in the middle
of this and took advantage of all this
stagecraft and
that's what he did i think a lot of the
professional politicians they're
they're good enough on camera you know i
think they they're able to deliver a
speech that's been composed by uh for
them by their by their staff but they're
not able to improvise and do what what
trump does and attract attention uh to
the degree that he's able to do well
when you were covering this for rolling
stone did you develop a respect
for his campaign style or his ability to
not sure get votes respect is is an odd
word um i definitely understood and
appreciated what he was doing i think
i saw early on that trump was operating
on a different level from the other
candidates i mean there's a scene that i
describe in the book where um we're at
plymouth state university in new
hampshire and
you know the press is always in the
middle of the hall right we're roped off
we're behind a rope line and there's
these risers and the and the
the cameramen are
are standing there and
trump had started to make us part of the
act uh what he would do is he would in
the middle of his speech he would
interrupt himself and say look at these
these jerks these these vultures you
know they they hate me they you know
they've never traveled so far for an
event um you know they didn't believe i
could do this well
and the crowd would physically turn
toward us and sometimes it would start
to boo and hiss or throw things you know
and it got very menacing and to me this
was it was incredible because trump was
taking something that was incredibly
boring you know the american political
stump speech which is usually this very
lifeless uh event with this
very scripted careful kind of delivery
and he turned it into this immediate
physical menacing
wwe style uh
performance um and it was very memorable
for people you could see that they left
the the hall you know sort of worked up
into a lather and that was very unusual
for a political event and it was hard
not to miss how effective that was going
to be you relate the story on election
day that you were standing at trump
tower and somebody walked up to you and
asked if you're a reporter right yeah i
forget what he said exactly but i think
he swore at me and and when i said yes i
mean i had a lot of experiences like
that uh on the trail this year and this
to be fair had been happening for quite
a long time before trump even came on
the scene
reporters had been
more and more
um
unpopular over the years and trump
he used our own popularity in a really
interesting way because
being a billionaire from new york
he he theoretically had a huge
accessibility problem with ordinary
people in quote unquote flyover country
but what he did is he he made a common
enemy out of the media and he presented
us
as the elitist um you know upper class
enemy uh and he's what he basically said
is we both hate these people uh and that
was his link to the common man basically
um and so
that that trick of using us of bringing
us into the speech and making us
characters in the story was incredibly
effective for him it's we solved his
accessibility problem i thought you
called the american political system an
easy mark what do you mean by that well
again the
for example the you know what what trump
did
our political system more especially our
system of political media is set up in a
way that's totally irrational and
doesn't doesn't work well for the body
politic we're a commercial system of
media
which means that almost all the people
who are covering the presidential
election
they need to get ratings and
subscriptions and eyeballs and hits in
order to make money
and so anybody who who does those things
who gets ratings for for the media is
going to have a massive advantage over
anybody else
it doesn't matter what your policies are
if you're like donald trump when you
start making and you're making money for
the networks they're going to cover you
more and that was a major major
um factor early in the race i think you
know there was a statistic that
trump got 23 times the amount of tv
coverage that bernie sanders did and
that wasn't for any substantive reason
it was because trump was making the tv
stations and the newspapers and the
magazines money
and
the that vulnerability that we had to
somebody who
was a good commercial vehicle
made it very easy for somebody like
trump to come in and just sort of take
over the entire
spectacle
what's it like to travel in the
presidential campaign
reporting bubble
it's a very difficult and frustrating
[Music]
assignment the first time i did it
for a long stretch it was in 2004
and uh
you're you're basically stuck in the
same environment with the same people
over and over and over again for days
and days and weeks on end
um
and especially in the later stages of
the campaign when the uh the secret
service gets involved you're literally
trapped in this environment you can't
leave the rope line you have to stay
with the same people and talk to them
and you're you're stuck with the the
candidate the candidate's aides
and other reporters and they're the only
people you're getting information from
and so what happens
in this environment and i think this was
a big factor in what happened with trump
is that you just don't you don't spend a
lot of time talking to actual people and
you miss a lot of important phenomena
that are going on out there
and we get our information from things
like polls that tells us what's going on
you know and that's that's the how we
take the temperature of the people
but
it's not an accurate way of kind of
discerning what's going on uh and that
that kind of bubble
can be very stifling and suffocating and
strange also it's so it's a weird
atmosphere to live in for a long time
now reading your most recent couple of
books
tell me if i'm wrong about this but can
you draw a direct line from howard dean
to ron paul to dennis kucinich
to donald trump
i think so yeah i mean
they were
all they were all protest candidates
right to begin with um
the the difference was
that in the old days the press had
uh
the power to kind of
take these
um
you know these protest candidates and
kind of marginalize them right if we if
we thought if the the sort of
establishment media collectively decided
that a person like dennis kucinich was
not a fit for the presidency they would
just describe him as a as not really a
candidate and it would be subtle
sometimes and unsubtle at other times
and sometimes it would be
the candidate would be way at the edge
in the debate other times they would
describe the person as a fringe
candidate in the in the text
other times they would just simply not
cover the speeches um and they would
signal to to audiences who's the real
candidate who isn't the real candidate
right so we had the front runners and
these are the sort of curiosities um
what happened
this time around was that there was so
much animosity towards the system and
towards the establishment media and and
toward this whole
kind of beltway complex king-making
group that decided who gets to be
president who doesn't get to be
president that they that the voters
poured all their energy into candidates
like trump and bernie sanders who whose
main selling point was i don't belong to
that club right i mean that that's what
they did they stood up in front of
audiences and said look these people
over here they want to tell you who's
going to who your president is going to
be and and i'm defying that and vote for
me and people flock to those candidacies
so in the old days
yeah i mean i watched this as the press
basically tore apart candidates like uh
dean and kucinich and and also ron paul
um and they tried to do it to trump this
time except he just he defied the
instinct you know when we tried to get
rid of him he just he just wouldn't have
it and he wouldn't exit the stage
do you feel that rolling stone and
yourself are part of the mainstream
media
uh yeah i mean
yes and no
we've we've been around for so long uh
that we're i guess you would call us
legacy media now we're not corporate
media i think that's an important
distinction you know we're we're
privately owned
and so
um
but you know our coverage is kind of a
tradition uh now it's been around for 50
years and
um
you wouldn't describe us as uh
you know a threadbare alternative media
publication anymore i think that would
be an accurate description so we're
somewhere in between i would say if
somebody went back and read hunter s
thompson from 1972
could they relate to it today absolutely
hunter thompson's books are
are
timeless and they
you know i think of them more as as
being like great works of fiction than i
do uh you know journalism becomes
irrelevant after
in a very short period of time it's
pretty hard to read uh
you know journalism 50 60 years later
and really really get into it but hunter
thompson's books are like great novels
you know and i
the fear and loathing on the campaign
trail
i always think of as uh i wrote this
once
for one of the introductions to one of
those books that it reminded me of a
book like the castle or or the trial you
know because it's this incredible story
of a of
this guy
kind of searching for meaning and and
justice uh in this
horrible construction of fakeness and
and uh and lies and
and uh
and and treachery and and with these
awful villains populating the landscape
and and of course he's never quite able
to get there you know to find happiness
and truth and and uh and validation it's
just
those books are incredible to me i think
they're they'll last for another 100 200
years well let's go back to 2009 in your
book the great derangement
you
write in there that we were really
losing faith in our political and
national institutions at that point
yeah now this is something that that i
saw a long time ago
and worried about a lot
that there was a trend
uh on both the left and the right and
unfortunately in america we have to use
these catchphrases like left and right
because there's no other shorthand for
our politics i think it's inaccurate
sometimes we have to
but um
but people were
increasingly i think tuning out
the
quote-unquote mainstream media they were
going uh
and seeking out um their own
uh stranger sometimes more
conspiratorial media sources you know
the internet is a is an incredible uh
invention but one of the things that's
it's also really good at doing is
um matching people with their opinions
right so uh when people
read the news these days instead of just
turning on abc cbs or nbc like they did
in the in the 70s
now they can kind of craft their own
realities they can say well these are
the five publications that that describe
the world in a way that i agree with and
they go onto the internet and they read
those five things and that's how they
get their news and i think what what
started to happen at the end of the you
know the 2000s
was that people were
beginning to retreat into their own
camps and they were they increasingly
didn't have a common set of facts that
we were debating and that that i think
was the precursor to this election where
we we just couldn't agree on what the
facts were
is that
a negative
yeah i think so i think i think it's a
it's a bad thing
it's a bad thing when when the entire
society can't even agree on the terms of
an argument right i mean we don't really
debate each other
um
you know on issues or policies anymore
we
we disagree on the literal facts of the
argument right and and that is a very
difficult place for us to be if we can't
even agree on what happened
then it becomes very very difficult for
people to
come to any kind of rapprochement about
you know anything more substantive than
that and this has been going on for a
while now and i think it's a result of
the sort of fracturing of the media
landscape which is only getting more and
more fractured as time goes on i think i
think you know now
you rarely see a news organization that
tries
to reach the entire population we we go
demographic hunting now is what we do we
say
you know here are here are our readers
our viewers and we're going to craft the
news for that audience and they're going
to love us and these people won't and
that's unfortunate and in fact in a
recent rolling stone column
the title of it
you wrote roger ailes was one of the
worst americans ever yeah
well i was trying to
so roger ailes died in getting back to
hunter thompson i was i was thinking
about his um famous obituary of
of uh nixon um
which you know an obituary
can can be
uh a really interesting thing to write
and i i always remembered
what he said about nixon that
he was so crooked that he needed
servants to help him unscrew his pants
in the morning
but
so i was trying to do something similar
for roger ailes but roger ailes um
you know to me was was a main driver of
this phenomenon of
let's let's let's target a demographic
let's give them news that they like and
let's forget about these other people
over here and they
you know he talked about it he said my
my audience is age 50 55 to dead um you
know they don't even want to hear about
uh you know
working women or liberals they just
don't want to exist and they crafted a
news program that was for that audience
and that that started us down the road
of this divided media landscape i think
uh where we're
basically looking we're
a population that's split into camps and
we each have our own news sources and we
don't agree on anything and i think he
was a pioneer in that in that factor
but matt tavi to go back to the what you
call the 70s and when we all listen to
the same news
was it good that nbc abc and cbs
essentially in many ways controlled what
we heard what we thought no i mean look
it was a it was an information monopoly
um you know i read manufacturing consent
when i was a young person and i totally
agree with with with the premise of the
book which is that um
it's very easy to control uh the
opinions of the population if you only
have a few a few media sources and they
were almost entirely simpatico they were
always in line with the policy
objectives of the kind of permanent
government of the united states and all
that stuff is was tremendously negative
it wasn't diverse you know i mean i i i
grew up in the media my father was in
the media and
um
you know it was a very different kind of
of news landscape the only thing i'm
saying
that i would say in its favor
was that they
they had a different attitude towards
the purpose of the news back then so the
original conception
of of how the news was supposed to work
was you know if you go back to the
telecommunications act of the 30s
um
the idea was the government would lease
the airwaves to these private companies
and in exchange
these private companies were supposed to
provide a public service in the form of
meaningful news and so they were
supposed to make their money
doing you know uh
entertainment or sports and then news
was supposed to be a loss leader um and
uh it didn't have to be profitable and
there was they were only there to you
know in their minds to to present
something that was factual and and
useful to the public and
even though it was incredibly biased and
and
uh
you know led us into wars like you know
vietnam
and
and excluded lots of voices it's still
there was a
there was an urge there to try to get
the story correct that isn't necessarily
true now now i think we're basically
crafting an entertainment product for
people
and people consume the news as
the same way they consume entertainment
which is unfortunate
back to the great derangement from 2009
the derangement that i describe in this
book kicked off when americans finally
figured out that they'd been betrayed by
their mainstream political system but
still failed to abandon that old
paradigm completely
yeah um
well
it wasn't like we had a revolution right
i mean i think they they there was a
frustration uh with with people they
they didn't trust
um
uh they're politicians they didn't trust
the media but they didn't have an
alternative that they particularly
trusted either so there was just a lot
of kind of incoherent frustration and
anger out in the population that was
kind of looking for an outlet and i
think that left us right for things like
what happened last year with donald
trump i mean there was just an enormous
number of people who were discontent um
and
and they were looking for any kind of
change almost
irrespective of what the change was we
saw these amazing polls last year that
two out of three people favored a new
direction and they didn't care what the
direction was
uh and that hugely favored somebody like
trump
he came in and he and his main argument
to people was
you know whatever you think of me i'm
not i'm not what you've experienced
before and that was you know that was
very attractive to people
because you were critical
many times in your writing about donald
trump did people assume that you
supported hillary clinton
well that's yeah that's unfortunately a
consequence of how uh
again how americans consume the media
now um
it's assumed that if you write something
negative about one party that you must
support the other party and this again
is a consequence of the politicized
media uh that you know i think that
people like roger rails pioneered um
you know where
if you are saying something negative
about the clintons that therefore you
must be a conservative and and that
unfortunately is this kind of
materialist view of
of what news is as opposed to just being
you know sometimes
people will have you know negative
feelings about both candidates or or
they're just trying to be objective and
trying to call things as they are it's
not necessarily a political act to to
cover somebody in a positive or a
negative way
from insane clown president by the way
where did that the name of that book
come from
uh well there's uh there's a band called
insane clown posse that uh
and i you know i was trying to come up
with something that was
in
hanging around donald trump for a year
makes you
not want to be subtle in your marketing
ideas so
that was that was just that yeah
who did the drawing on the front
um
of insane clown president that's uh
victor yuhas he's the um illustrator for
rolling stone he and i he's he's amazing
he and i've worked together for you know
over a decade now and um
he has the same
basically disturbed sense of humor that
i do so it's uh we had a lot of fun
during the campaign and from that book
the clintons probably should have left
politics the moment they decided they
didn't care what the public thought
about how they made their money
yeah well i thought that was an amazing
detail and some of the reporting
that's come out
among other things in books like
shattered
they describe this moment where
hillary clinton
essentially said
when she was trying to decide whether or
not to accept
what ultimately turned into over 100
million dollars in speaking fees uh
by taking this tour of all the various
you know banks and big corporations
um she said you know they're going to
write negative things about me whatever
i do all right and i think that was the
substance of the quote i can't remember
exactly what you said um
but i think you know that's when you're
in that place as a politician
and
you're basically saying it doesn't
matter what i do anymore you know people
are going to hate me no matter what
then what that basically means is that
you're in my mind that means you're no
longer
really worrying about what the public
thinks about you which i think is a
dangerous place for a politician to be
good afternoon and welcome to book tv on
cspan2 this is our monthly in-depth
program this is where we invite one
author on to talk about his or her body
of work and this month from our new york
studio we have
rolling stone correspondent and author
matt taibi mr taibi is the author of
several books his first one came out in
2000 it's called the exile sex drugs and
libel in the new russia
spanking the donkey dispatches from the
dumb season came out in 2005
smells like dead elephants dispatches
from a rotting empire came out in 2007
the great derangement which we've talked
about a little bit a terrifying true
story of war politics and religion 2009
his most recent books are griftopia a
story of bankers politicians and the
most audacious power grab in american
history 2011
the divide came out in 2014 american
injustice in the age of the wealth gap
and finally this past year insane clown
president dispatches from the 2016
circus this is your chance to call in
and talk with mr taibi about his work
about politics here's how you can do so
202 is the area code 748 8200 for those
of you in the east and central time zone
748-8201
if you live in the mountain and pacific
time zones now if you can't get through
on the phone lines still want to make a
comment we've got some social media ways
for you to get through including twitter
at book tv is our twitter handle if you
send a tweet and use that uh we'll be
able to see it and and maybe use it you
can also make a comment on our facebook
page facebook.com slash book tv if you
go to go down you'll see a piece there
with mr taibi
and you can just make a comment
underneath there we'll get those
comments on the air as well and finally
you can send an email to book tv
at
cspan.org and we'll begin taking those
calls in just a few minutes
mr tayeb how did you get into this
business
uh well it's
it's the family business actually my
father almost everybody i knew growing
up was a reporter my my father
um was a news reporter starting from the
age of 18.
and uh
and that's mike mike tybee yeah he
worked here in new york at wcvbs and
wnbc for a long time he's just
sort of retiring now he does a little
work for pbs but he was in the business
for 50 years
um my
stepmother was an anchor at cnn for a
while
business anchor what's her name beverly
shook um
and a lot of
you know my
family friends growing up they worked in
places like the international herald
tribune and
so
you know my childhood was basically like
the movie anchorman you know i spent
most of my you know formative years and
you know local television affiliates
with you know guys with bad facial hair
and stuff like that and so i i actually
never wanted to do this for a living um
but uh i wanted to be a novelist but
when it turned out that my fiction was
was pretty bad i i sort of fell back
into the family business and and um and
so i've been here ever since when did
you know you were a writer
i always wanted to be a writer uh
from the age of maybe 11 or 12. i think
you know that was never a question in my
mind um
i had a
really deep love of books when i was
growing up i was an only child we moved
a lot uh books were you know a
tremendous solace to me you know um you
know i was depressed a lot and then you
know i when i started to learn how to
write
um i became really obsessed with the
idea you know writing is almost like a
religion if you really get into it it's
it's uh
you can never really
um
you complete the task of being perfect
at it so you have to constantly try to
practice getting better and better and
better and and uh
i became really addicted to it at a very
young age uh i wanted to be a comic
novelist you know my heroes were all
funny writers um people like you know
sake and nikolai goggle and
bulgakov you know who wrote a heart of a
dog and master and margarita books like
that
catch-22
evelyn wah evelyn hua
so these were the things that i wanted
that's what i wanted to do when i grew
up and um
i spent a lot of my early you know early
years and my teens tried
trying to do that kind of thing and it
just didn't work out but um
but you know journalism is has been
great in a different way you know i
think uh
it's
it's a term it's an amazing profession
because it it allows you to see the
whole world um
and meet this extraordinary range of
people and um you know it's been great
in in a way that probably was more
fulfilling than than sitting at home and
being a fiction writer would have been
you said that you were depressed a lot
why
i don't know some people are just
depressive i you know
but do you think it's organic but i
think it probably is yeah i think most
people who who who have that problem
would tell you that it's just a chemical
thing in your brain
um interestingly a lot of the people who
were kind of my heroes
um
also had the same problem i remember
reading about you know gogol who was a
um
you know a famous russian writer and he
was a terrible depressive uh and
he
conquered it by sitting at home and
trying to think of the funniest things
that he could all day long and he would
write those things down and that that's
how that's how he got through it
um and that's you know that was that was
something that i did a lot in my my teen
years i
uh i tried to write funny stories and
things like that and that was uh that
was a way of kind of
making sense of the world
on your bio it says that you were the
sports editor for the moscow times how
did that come about
yeah so one of my first jobs was i was i
was living in russia i studied in russia
um
in
1990 and 91
so i was there when it was communist and
then i was there i
went home they had a revolution then i
came back
and
i i loved it over in russia so much
one of the reasons actually was that
you know as a young often depressed
teenager and 20 something uh
you know america was very difficult
place for me to because there's enormous
pressure in america to be successful and
happy and you turn into television
everyone has perfect teeth and they're
all you know thrilled in russia
everybody was depressed you know when i
got there you know people were drab and
nobody had nice clothes and
and i thought i fit right in here this
is perfect you know so um
i
when i went to study there i just didn't
come home and uh
before long i ended up needing a job and
so i started stringing for various uh
newspapers and
uh and sooner or later i ended up
meeting people in moscow they had an
ex-patriot newspaper there
and since i had a sports background
they gave me the sports editor's job so
that's how i did that how did you end up
playing professional basketball in
mongolia
so i i i had played basketball in
college in in the states uh you know for
for bard college here in new york um you
know i'm an okay
you know
division three basketball player
basically and and uh i was
i played a lot of street ball in moscow
and i was out at moscow state university
one day
and um i met this kid we were playing a
game three on three and he told me he
was from willenbotter which is you know
the capital of mongolia
and he told me about a league they had
there the mba the mongolian basketball
association he said it was the only
league in the world that had nba rules
uh outside of america
and
and it just sounded so like so much fun
i went into work the next day and quit
my job
and uh i packed up my stuff i got on the
trans february and railroad uh for will
and bata and when i got there i got to
try out and got on one of the teams
and uh i would have stayed there for a
long time i was really having a great
time except i got quite ill and ended up
having to come home
um but uh you know it was cool that was
like a you know a sports star there and
you know people would recognize me on
the streets and stuff it was it was
great i was known as the mongolian
rodman
believe it or not
matt tabi it's been written about and
you've written about your drug use
and
why is that important for us to know
i don't know if it's important for
anybody to know i just didn't
particularly feel and need to deny it i
think
um
you know i i
had a period there in russia we had a
newspaper called the exile
um
where which was like a nightlife guide
and
you know we were young
in a town that was very much like the
wild west you know communism but just
collapsed it was it was crazy uh at the
time and you know we were doing a lot of
crazy things and
um
i did have a pretty serious drug problem
at one point uh and
you know it's not that i particularly
want anybody to know about it but when i
guess when somebody asked i'll i'll
admit to it you know
you've been with rolling stone since
2005 your book griftopia came out in
2011.
and in that book you write that alan
greenspan's rise to the top is one of
the great scams of our time
yeah um
so
alan greenspan was a character i
originally had planned on doing just the
2000 word uh little section on him
because he was so important to
the whole history of the modern
financial services industry
his his attitude you know he has a this
philosophy that's derived her a lot from
iron rand you know he was an acolyte of
hers
and
he was fascinating to me as a character
because he was very famous for being
this great predictor of economic events
but when i actually went back and looked
it turned out that he had been wrong
about almost everything that he'd ever
predicted uh and
um
and so he was mostly you know sort of
like a lot of famous uh hangers on who
you know who hang around rock bands or
um other celebrities he was famous for
for being somebody who
was really good at uh telling
politicians what they wanted to hear
uh and and that that
gift of being like a president whisperer
i think really
was what uh allowed him to serve in the
capacity that he did for so long it
wasn't that he was so great an economist
he really wasn't uh it was just more
that he was a very skilled politician
and
and that was what i was trying to
demonstrate in that book and the divide
came out in 2014
in the end
the one bank to get thrown on the dock
was not a wall street firm but one
housed in the opposite direction a
little to the north a tiny family-owned
community bank in chinatown
called abacus federal savings bank
yeah in fact there's a movie out about
it now called abacus small enough to
jail um this is a an amazing an
incredible story because this uh it's a
tiny
uh sort of family-owned
chinese immigrant bank uh in chinatown
it's stuck between two noodle shops
uh and it was the only bank in america
to be indicted after the financial
crisis
and they were indicted because
uh
of a a series of very small
improprieties that they themselves
reported
uh to the authorities um there was they
were eventually uh
prosecuted for defrauding fannie mae uh
but fenney may never suffered a single
cent of loss in any of those
transactions so what i was trying to
show in that book
was you know here you have this tiny
regional bank that's surrounded by all
these behemoth
financial institutions that later
settled for billions of dollars for
committing crimes on massive scales far
beyond what abacus had ever did but none
of them were criminally prosecuted
and that was because we have this new
doctrine in america which is too big to
too big to fail
and too big to jail
we
have openly said
people like former attorney general or
eric holder
have said that um
you know that they were reluctant to
prosecute certain companies because they
were worried about the
uh quote unquote collateral consequences
and what that might do to the larger
economy um and so you know the converse
of that is if we're if we're afraid to
prosecute a big bank because we're
concerned that it's going to upset the
economy well that means that there's
certain you have to be small enough uh
to be able to prosecute right i mean so
that's what that's what happened in the
case of abacus they found a bank that
was just small small enough to prosecute
um and so they indicted them but uh very
recently they were they were all found
not guilty and um and so it's an amazing
story and i i highly recommend everybody
watch the movie too it was it's an
uplifting story well july 9 2013 you
were in the courtroom when cyrus fans jr
was the prosecutor and essentially these
people were marched through in chains
right yeah yeah and some of them had
actually already been arraigned and they
brought them back a second time for a
photo op you think about this like
you know not one of the major bankers
whoever who got in trouble uh or who
were accused of wrongdoing after 2008
none of them had to appear so much as a
appear in a courtroom you know all of
these big deals between you know the
settlements between companies like jp
morgan chase and
or goldman sachs they were all done in
in back rooms and there was just an uh
you know an exchange of money um
nobody had to sit in the dock nobody had
to be publicly humiliated uh but when
you had this small
uh immigrant bank
they needed a photo opportunity so what
did they do they they indicted a bunch
of people and they literally got them in
a chain gang and dragged them into the
courtroom and you know the excuse the
prosecutors gave later was that that
wasn't up to us that was up to the
bailiffs in the in in the courthouse
but clearly it was a political thing and
and it was then
and the the purpose of telling that
story was to show the the dichotomy and
how we treat different kinds of people
you know when we're talking about a a
group of people who don't have power
influence or connections we treat them
one way and when they do have
connections you know they never see the
inside of a courtroom and
i sensed a feeling of outrage on your
part reading this book of course of
course and
and i think outrage is an important
component of being a reporter i mean i
think if you
if you aren't in touch with
what's uh outrageous then it's very
difficult to do this job and yeah and
you have to maintain your sense of that
throughout the years one of the things
that happens to people who
who are in the press for a long long
time
is you get outrage fatigue after a while
you've seen so much horrible stuff and
so much bad behavior that you stop
responding to things in the way that a
normal person would um and that's that's
something you have to guard against as
you get as you get older you know this
feeling of you know i've seen that
before you have to continually say this
is not acceptable you know and find ways
to get upset about it
from the divide
we have a profound hatred of the weak
and the poor and a corresponding
groveling terror before the rich and
successful and we're building a
bureaucracy to match those findings
yeah
what i was trying to say there was
that the
underlying political
um
[Music]
what drives the policies that lead to
mass incarceration
to you know things like stop and frisk
community policing where we're stopping
500 000 600 000 people a year emptying
their pockets and
throwing people in jail for nickel bags
and dime bags on the one hand uh and
then we take people like hsbc you know
one of the world's largest banks that
gets caught
uh laundering 800 million dollars for
narco terrorists and in you know central
and south america
and you know we don't even prosecute
those people they they uh you know they
just pay a fine and walk away i think
the
what's underlying the the policy divide
there is that we
we feel like x group of people
we we worship the people who make money
we we have a
reverence an admiration for people who
uh are quote unquote wealth creators and
the people who we see as parasites and
nuisances well you know
we have no sympathy for them whatsoever
they belong in jail you know i i i had
an experience that was really
eye-opening for me during
when i was writing that book
and i i asked the prosecutor in
washington i said how can you let these
guys
who laundered 800 million dollars in
drug money how can you let them walk and
not go to jail if we're sending people
to jail for possession uh you know on
the other hand um these guys got to go
sit in jail and and what he said to me
was have you been to a prison those
places are dangerous you know and he
didn't mean it in an ironic way what
what he was really trying to say without
without really you know admitting it was
i just don't see that kind of offender
as deserving jail you know no matter
what he or she does um but these
offenders well you know they grew up in
these bad neighborhoods and they're used
to that kind of thing so so of course we
send them to jail and that's that's what
i was trying to get at this
psychological um split that we have
where we
we just have this hidden hostility
towards uh people who you know are are
poor and without means and we
we fear and revere these other people
and
not to go on about this too much but you
know i had an
experience in russia that was that was
um
that gave me some insight into this when
i was a
a student in the soviet union
when i went to school in the morning i
would see these uh these kids uh selling
blue jeans and rabbit hats and stuff
like that and of course that was
commerce so that was against the law in
in communist russia and every now and
then those kids would disappear for
three or four weeks you know they'd do a
little bit in jail and and they would
come back meanwhile the people they were
selling to you know they would sell
socks and t-shirts and clothes to the
you know the party members who were the
the running the school
you know nobody ever did anything to
them and that was because in it was so
ingrained in soviet society that
the party members don't get in trouble
but these people do get in trouble and i
think
that kind of unspoken split is where we
are as a country and it's it's just hard
to reconcile with it's a class split
it's yeah i think it's a class split um
it goes beyond that too though i mean i
think i mean clearly race is a huge
factor also you know i think
i think white
audiences probably wouldn't want to
admit it but they would look differently
at you know uh
you know a poor black person who
gets busted with you know a bag of weed
in his or her pocket than they would a
white kid who gets busted for the same
thing they would say oh he's just going
through a phase you know is what they
would say you know all kids kids will be
kids
um but you know they would say something
very different you know about a black
kid who gets pulled over and has drugs
found on them so i think you know it's
racist classes all those things before
we leave the divide you also
visited california and went through
their welfare system right what was that
experience
well i mean again
what i was trying to show is because a
lot of the the big banks and financial
companies that i'd covered
um
a lot of them were technically guilty of
crimes like fraud right you know i would
talk to whistleblowers and things like
that and they explained to me like look
if you wanted to prosecute these people
here's the statute that they're guilty
of right it was always be like some kind
of fraud statute
so i looked at
how they treated those people and then i
wanted to see how they treated people
who committed crimes like welfare fraud
and um what that experience was like was
you know i would talk to people who are
on welfare and they would tell me
stories about how
you'd have to fill up this gigantic sort
of
complex of forms just to get the aid in
the first place and then what they would
do is they would check every single item
that you entered every like on a monthly
basis and they had you know this whole
network of computers uh is constantly
searching your record and if there's any
inconsistency at all they automatically
generate a fraud case and you will
either be prosecuted for it or you'll
have your benefits taken away your
family's benefits will be taken away
they can enter your home at any time
there's a supreme court case that says
that they can do that um you know if
once you're taking public aid
so i was just trying to show that again
this dichotomy and how we treat people
like you can't you couldn't just go and
uh
you know seize the books of a company
that's committed uh
you know fraud uh like a mortgage
subprime mortgage fraud they would treat
them very differently than they would
treat somebody who who committed welfare
fraud and they would punish them much
more severely for the welfare fraud than
for the 100 million dollar fraud
so
i was just trying to show how
even getting that aid is a constant
struggle to avoid being prosecuted for
misusing the funds whereas you know
people who enjoy the largest for
instance of the um you know the the
federal reserve uh you know banking
window they're borrowing billions of
dollars and months of these gigantic uh
banks
um
you know the government doesn't do
anything there's no surveillance or
anything like that in that area so again
i'm i was just trying to show the
differing attitudes towards these two
classes of people do you hear from your
rolling stone readers
oh yeah absolutely yeah and and i hear
from people on twitter and
um
and i make it a point to read you know
if anybody writes
hate mail or
a critical letter if if somebody takes
the time to actually sit down and write
me a letter uh i always read it i think
it's important to read your hate your
hate mail
not everybody does it i don't block
anybody on social media
uh i think i think often
you know
you need that's one of the ways you get
better as a writer is you listen to your
readers and sometimes they tell you you
know
this thing that you tried didn't work it
wasn't funny it sucked
and you have to listen to that
so
matt tybee
is it easy or
is it
is one susceptible to being brought into
the group think when you're traveling on
a campaign and you're in this bubble
with other reporters
is there a group think susceptibility
absolutely yeah i mean
it's it's a social thing it's a class
thing um
again
just to talk about the differences
between when i when i was a kid
um and around the people who my father
worked with
you know reporting was more like a trade
than a profession back then uh there
were a lot of people who were in the
press who didn't go to college you know
they went they were like this
they they got in sort of via the seymour
hirsch method you know they they would
become they would be copy boys at age 16
and they would just
work their way through and it was it was
a job more like being a plumber or or a
uh you know an electrician than it was
like being a doctor or a lawyer and
back then
i think those people didn't have any
affinity for politicians or the rich
they were they tended to have this kind
of like stick it to the man attitude um
of course they were it was a far less
diverse group of people on the one hand
but they were you know in terms of class
they were very much more working-class
group of people back in the day now
when you're on the campaign plane
you see
a lot of people who are like me they
come from privileged backgrounds they
went to really good schools they're they
tend to be white
and well-off
and they get into this business
very often because they're attracted to
the idea of being near power and
powerful people they want to hang out
after the speech with
you know the candidate's aides or the or
the candidate
his or herself and
you would never have seen that 30 or 40
years ago this desire to be behind the
rope line with with the politician back
then the politician was kind of the
enemy you know
um
and what i've definitely seen lately is
that
socially the media and the people
they're covering are the same people you
know
after the campaigns are over they hang
out with each other you know the the
the
political strategists and the aids and
the pollsters they go to the same bars
and adams morgan and the upper west side
and
um i don't know that that's a healthy
thing i mean it's it may be it may not
be but it's certainly different from
what it used to be
in your book insane clown president
you're very critical
of the mannequin
what happened oh the the hillary clinton
the mannequin video
yeah i mean i think
that might have been a little gratuitous
that you know at the time this was right
after the election i wrote that and i
remember looking at that uh the
mannequin challenge i think they called
it right
and it was a bunch of people who um
were on the plane together and it was
press
and
the clinton's aides and and the clintons
and i think john bon jovi was on that in
that shot as well
um
and what happens again when when you're
in that environment for a long time
um it becomes romanticized hey we're all
on this adventure together you know
isn't it cool that we're all hanging out
hanging out together and there are
celebrities in the plane and
we're all friends
and um
that congenial atmosphere
you can you see it in books like primary
colors right or movies like that where
it's just
this uh they kind of lionize the the
whole idea of the of the roving campaign
but they were you know they there was
this disaster looming all outside the
plane and they were completely unaware
of it of it happening i mean they they
probably all should have been panicking
uh instead of playing that goofy goofy
game i don't know i mean
i i i've had a it's not exclusive to the
clintons i've i've
seen that kind of thing in a couple of
different campaigns i was in a a plane
in the obama campaign once where
i came in and i noticed that there all
the reporters had
um uh photos had taken photos of
themselves with barack obama and then
posted it on the you know they would
stick them on the side of the plane in
the press section
and you know i i liked barack obama i
voted for him but you know i thought
that was kind of a bad look for us you
know we we didn't want to be acting like
groupies you know even just
just superficially it looked bad you
know and so i i think that's what i was
trying to get to with that mannequin
challenge is you know we
even if we even if we do like the people
we're hanging out with in the plane we
have to kind of pretend at least that
we're separate you know maintain that
distance um
because it's a bad look when we get
caught you know uh making a mistake like
we made in this in this race
we got it entirely wrong from start to
finish and that that's bad for us
in your columns you've also been
critical of tom friedman the new york
times columnist
yeah
i mean
i i actually kind of enjoy reading tom
friedman i mean
what i've really gotten after with tom
friedman is his writing style um
you know he's
he's famous for um mixing metaphors uh
and
um
some of them are
are so strange that it's almost like a
psychedelic experience try to follow
what he's trying to say you know he'll
uh yeah
like he compared once
um
the iraq war to driving a car with no
steering wheel he's like sometimes you
just have to throw the wheel out you
know and
but you can't drive a car with no
steering wheel you know what i mean or
he'll say um you know he has a famous
thing the rule of holes he says
uh
you know when you're in
when you're in a hole that's too deep um
you should stop when you're in three
holes you should stop digging like you
can't be in three holes at once you know
and there's just all these bizarre
images that are kind of mismatched in
his writing and i actually really enjoy
writing it and
i met him once and he was very gracious
to me and i felt i felt really bad about
saying negative things about him so
it's not directed at him as a person i
just find his writing really interesting
what's the origin of the name taibi
taibi is a um
it's
a sicilian name of arabic origin um i'm
neither of those things my father is
adopted uh he is um
filipino and hawaiian uh
and
he was adopted by a sicilian family here
in in new york uh
and so that's where that name comes from
matt tybee is our guest rolling stone
correspondent and author his most recent
book is insane clown president here's
what the cover looks like phone numbers
to dial in 202 748 8200 if you live in
the eastern central time zone
202-748-8201 for those of you in the
mountain and pacific and tyler in
marietta georgia you've been very
patient you are on the air tyler go
ahead
i'm matt do you feel that the media is
being complicit in the terrorist attacks
the media is acting as you know the
propaganda arm for the terrorist bike
providing your non-stop coverage
of their attacks i mean why doesn't the
media get this i know they're probably
doing it because they want to generate
more you know
more ratings and generate more profits i
mean what are your thoughts on this
that's an interesting question tyler i
hadn't thought about it from that point
of view
clearly
terrorism doesn't work if nobody sees it
so
um
on the one hand there is
there's probably some truth to that but
on the other hand
uh it would be hugely irresponsible not
to cover these things at the same time
so i don't i don't know exactly
uh what the
happy medium is there you know there may
be a way to do it that's less
sensational than um
than the way that we do do it certainly
um
you know more people die in domestic
murders overwhelmingly than they do in
terrorist attacks but we worry a lot
more about terrorism on the news um
so that's
that's definitely uh you know a
consideration but yeah clearly
um yeah i wouldn't necessarily say that
we're complicit in it i just think it's
it's probably there's probably a way
that we could do it that that wouldn't
um
wouldn't quite amplify the effect that
they're looking for quite as much
because
to be frank people are so scared of
terrorists now
um that they've made
some crazy political decisions as a
result uh you know dating back to 911
and a lot of that has to do with the nut
sort of bombardment of coverage that you
get whenever there is a terrorist attack
so yeah that's a good point do you find
yourself when
things like what happened hasn't been
happening in london do you find yourself
turning on the tv immediately i don't
you know um
you know again i lived in moscow when
terrorist attacks were pretty routine
the chechens were kind of routinely
bombing the city i
just missed uh being in a subway bombing
a couple of times actually um
and
you know i don't
i don't find that it's something that i
have to glue myself to the television to
watch um
it's a fact of life i you know i think
it's a very complicated
political dilemma but
you know
getting myself worked up about it is not
i don't think it's helpful so
you know but
clearly there is something to the to the
idea that
scaring people is a way to get them to
tune into
your network and terrorists are scary so
there there is a commercial motive there
and
you know it might be worth unpacking
that a little bit well i can't find
which book or article it is but you have
a quote saying that the best story for
cnn is somebody has fallen down the well
and the best story for fox is that
somebody was pushed down the well by a
radical muslim terrorist right yeah
exactly yeah but the point i was trying
to make there is that
both the formula for in the liberal
media and the conservative media it's
basically the same formula we're both
looking for the same kind of
sensationalist stories it's just that
the
the fox version tends to be
you know
tilted in a direction if they can manage
it you know that their their favorite
story will tend to involve some kind of
uh you know political nemesis whether
it's
you know a liberal professor or a or an
islamic terrorist or you know god knows
who else but yeah exactly next call from
matt taibi comes from nancy in redondo
beach california hi nancy
hi good morning guys thank you peter so
much and and thanks for c-span and matt
i've followed you for a very long time
um and my question is that my sense is
when a journalist or a reporter is going
to write a story or a book
most of the time it's to kind of confirm
what they already believe and they may
ignore what they don't want to see or
contradicts what they initially believed
and i'm wondering for you personally has
there been a time where you thought when
you went into a story and you thought it
was going to be one way and it turned
out to be completely different and is it
possible for reporters and journalists
to not be biased um i'll take my answer
off the air and thanks again
thank you nancy great question thank you
nancy that's a great question um
uh
to answer the last part first um
no i i believe that every
all coverage is biased i don't think you
can have uh
i think objectivity in the way that they
teach it in journalism school is kind of
a myth because every every decision you
make editorially
speaks to
your point of view on things so just to
take an example even if you're
looking at the new york times and
they're
covering something in that kind of
unemotional third-person voice uh and
they're trying to give
equal weight to different points of view
but
even the the choice of whether to put
something on the front page or in the in
the middle on the top of the page or at
the bottom whether to have a picture or
not a picture whether to make the
headline a scare headline or
less threatening all those things speak
to they're all editorial decisions and
they all speak to what your opinion on
this on the subject is so
um i think
uh
there's always bias
and
um there are a lot of different ways to
handle it i i try to be just sort of
open about it and when i'm covering
something i'll say
and this is what i think about the
subject in terms of the other thing
um about
the confirmation bias which is the sort
of second problem
that is a huge issue in our business
because
among other things now speed is such a
factor in in how
the commercial media works you have to
you have to be as quick as possible and
generating your content and one of the
ways you do that is by knowing what
you're going to say beforehand you know
you if you're going to do a story on
let's say
middle class
white suburbanites who left the
republican party to
the traditional republican party to vote
for donald trump what you'll do is
you'll go to an event you'll look for
people like that you'll ask them leading
questions that tend to confirm your
thesis and then as soon as you get those
quotes you just dump them in the story
and and you publish it and that's that's
not a good way to do business i think
it's much better to enter into a subject
uh in a way that's open-ended and
that allows you the freedom to kind of
go in a different direction
i've definitely had the experience of of
covering a story
and thinking it was going to be one
thing and then
having it turn out to be something
completely different
i've had the experience of
expecting somebody to be guilty of
something when i started investigating
and having it turned out that they
weren't and had to abandon the story you
have to have the freedom to not write
too that's another important thing and a
lot of reporters don't have that freedom
um
so yeah i think that's that's kind of a
key thing unfortunately again because of
the way our business is structured it's
just really hard to allow reporters the
latitude to
to kind of go where the facts lead them
as opposed to just cranking out content
let's hear from phyllis in brooklyn new
york hi phyllis
hi i have a question about health care
specifically
the members of congress what kind of
health care do they have
how much is their deductible and their
co-pay
do their plans cover abortion and birth
control
how
old are their children on their health
plans how long do they keep these health
plans for life and who funds their
health plan
um
phyllis right that's a great question i
actually don't know the answer to that
um i i do know that they
the members of congress do enjoy a
federal health insurance program or at
least they did up until very recently a
lot until the last time i covered the
health insurance story um
so yeah we're paying for their health
insurance and
and
that of course
adds to the
perversity of members of congress
moving to take away health insurance
from people so um
but i think that information is easily
discoverable if you just go on the
internet and look for it
this is an email question from floor
flor in california with your experience
in the former soviet union what's your
take on the current putin trump bromance
and subversion of the u.s political
system if trump were a democratic
president might he be tarred and
feathered by the right
also what similarities did you find
between the russian and american
national characters
uh
so what's your take first of all yeah
so
um
you know i've taken a little bit of heat
for this
for being kind of a skeptic on this
russia story
um
and
you know my concern with the story is
not first of all i'm politically i think
it's pretty clear i'm not a big fan of
donald trump
you know i certainly wouldn't shed a
tear if he were impeached
but
my concern about the russia story is
that it's been very sloppily reported
it's been reported in a way that lends
uh its people to excesses
um
just to give you an example you know the
the steele dossier that was released
uh
you know
no responsible
news outlet would ever touch that and
when buzzfeed published that
it's set in motion a chain of events
um that i think was very unfortunate
because we you know as a
as reporters we you know
we
as a rule don't publish unverifiable
accusations of crimes against people for
the simple reason that we wouldn't want
that to happen to us uh and so um
when we did this with trump with this
dossier that had this explosive
uh set of allegations in it
but was totally unverifiable
um
you know now it's all over the internet
and it's a you know
we have millions and millions of people
who sort of believe
uh implicitly that this this thing is
true
and it's led to
you know audience having audiences
coming to news stories about this with a
set of expectations they already believe
a certain set of facts has been
confirmed
when
you know we don't know for a fact
exactly what happens what's happened
this story i spent months on this and
this is an example
of what i was just talking about about
not writing when you can't find
uh you know what the truth is i every
time i try to actually get
hold of something concrete with this
story
i just kept coming up with dead ends and
suppositions and anonymous sources who
who wouldn't you know
come up with verifiable concrete
information so
i worry a lot about the story um
i think it's
it could be a disaster for
our system of media if this turns out
not to be true and um i just worry that
we're getting in over our skis with this
thing
you say you've gotten the treatment
though
from others yeah well
and this is one of the things that i
worry about which is when um
when people are emotional enough about a
story that they uh attack somebody
for you know there's a new term out
there for people who don't believe uh
the russia thing uh they call them
anti-anti-trumpers
right uh and so
they're
what they're accusing people of is
basically aiding and abetting donald
trump we're the russians you know i've
been accused of being a russian agent uh
you know because among other things
because i lived in russia for a long
time um
but what happens when people see that
happening to people like me and even
though i may not worry about that
criticism
other people might and they'll think
twice about about
saying well i'm not sure about this you
know and when it it silences people and
and that's not a positive thing um
people become afraid to speak their
minds and uh and it this these stories
generate a momentum everybody knows that
it's easy to get hits and followers on
twitter by fueling this thing and then
they know that the opposite will happen
if they express any skepticism about
this thing and
that's not a positive situation you
don't want people
being afraid to say what they see you
know and uh and
the media in particular
i saw this starting to happen last year
before this this tr this russia thing
even
took place uh
i there was a
a shift and even there were even people
like jim ruttenberg in the new york
times who wrote about this openly they
said trump is such an extreme character
he's such a threat
that we in the media have to rethink our
traditional kind of objective posture
towards things and start to become
advocates and and start to think of
ourselves as a way as a force
that will stop him
and
i think a lot of people in our business
have adopted that
attitude and what's dangerous about that
attitude is that it it undercuts our
power institutionally in the media the
the media derives its power
entirely from its independence if we are
seen as being part of the democratic
party or part of a resistance effort
that aids one party over another then we
completely lose our legitimacy we have
to be seen as only being about one thing
and that's the truth right and when
we're seen about as being about
something else
then
then we're useless to people we don't
have any real function in society we
have to be separate it's kind of like
when
you know the senate
uh
in order to help barack obama uh
push through his nominees they you know
they they got rid of their ability to
filibuster uh presidential nominees
um a couple years ago because
uh they wanted to you know end the
gridlock in in washington
and that seemed like a great idea at the
progressives at the time right because
it it helped people get through and do
their work
but look what happened three years later
now the senate is too weak uh the
minority party can't filibuster
trump's nominees and the senate undercut
itself it undercut its own institutional
authority on behalf of somebody else and
the media i think is doing that now we
by signing on with this kind of
resistance effort and making us
indistinguishable from that effort
we're losing our power and
we have to be seen as being separate and
that's what i worry about
floor another part of his or her
question was
differences or similarities russian and
american characters well
there are a lot of
there are a lot of differences and a lot
of similarities i think both countries
see them
their citizens view themselves as
um
you know as superpower nations uh and
they derive incredible pride um
in
the idea that they're different from
people who live in small countries that
don't affect uh everything on the on in
the world uh there was a i remember
being in the apartment of uh a russian
teacher um on the day that they
dismantled the soviet map um and they
changed the name from the ussr to the
the cis the i forget what that even
stands for in english but um basically
the the old soviet map became much
smaller it was as if the united states
became you know uh
23 states instead of 50.
and he looked at the new map and he he
was crying you know because he he had
grown up his whole life with this
gigantic 11 time zones expanse of a
superpower and he thought of himself as
part of this empire um
and now he wasn't anymore you know and i
think americans and russians both share
that idea that we are
part of the sort of deciding cadre in
the world hierarchy um
you know
both countries are heavily militarized
they tend to be much more macho than
other countries and you know
in terms of differences in i don't know
that's a long list you know americans
are um
uh
much more conservative i would say i
don't know that's a different i'll have
to think about that one um you have to
give me a little bit of time on that
well while you're thinking about that
matt taibi let's hear from walter in
cincinnati hi walter go ahead with your
question or comment hi matt uh i'd like
to have well first of all i think that
you're absolutely right that the media
has become a mouthpiece for the
democratic party but that's another
thing what i wanted to know is your
opinion of
of the writing of ali hersey ali who has
written a book i think it's called the
heretic her notion is that we will never
eliminate the jihadists by trying to
kill them all what we need to do is
support the notion of the
islamic world having a reformation
similarly to similar to what the
christian church did back in ways to
have to get out of being in the 7th
century and your opinion of that and why
that is not talked about i don't see it
on any television
nobody is talking about the idea of
having the islamic world having a
reformation
thanks
all right that's walter and cincinnati
are you
familiar with hersey ali i'm not i
haven't read her ciali's book um
you know the only thing i would say to
that walter is you know i have spent a
lot of time in the middle east uh
i
clearly don't agree with the idea of
that killing them all is going to solve
any kind of problem i think that we
exacerbate the problem when we do that
um
this is a
an issue that
has that i agree has to come from a
transformation within those societies
and it probably also has something to do
with um
you know
changing our attitudes towards those
societies i think that we would we
wouldn't have those
uh all of those those um
uh problems if we
hadn't had such a a powerful and
intrusive colonial presence in a lot of
those places for for so long and
hadn't had an interest in their oil
wealth and other issues so it's it's a
it's a definitely a complicated issue
but for sure
um
you know dropping bombs from uh
is not to me the way to go
this is a tweet from alan could you
comment on the phenomena of buyer's
remorse as it relates to voters who
supported trump
uh well i haven't seen a whole lot of
data uh
on how many people have
had that buyer's remorse i have seen
that trump's approval rating is now down
around 39 percent
um
[Music]
which is of course lower than
uh a little bit lower than where he was
in november um but the democrats have
also seen a significant drop in their
approval rating
since november they were at 45 and
they're now at 40. so
uh
i you know i think
people who voted for donald trump
um if they weren't turned off to him
before november they're probably not
going to be turned off to him i mean it
would take something
extraordinary like proof of him
conspiring with vladimir putin or
or some very very awful sexual scandal
or something like that to really get uh
people to move off their support of him
so it's it's like fandom you know you
you know how many people do you know
our you know minnesota vikings fans who
suddenly stop being minnesota vikings
fans that's the way politics is in
america now you it's a fanatical kind of
a relationship
uh in a lot of many cases and it's it's
hard to break that bond no matter you
live up here in new york city and you
write for rolling stone
what's been the general attitude of your
neighbors and friends and people in in
the city
towards donald trump
um
well almost everybody i know was
horrified by donald trump and
and
the dichotomy is not that hard to figure
out where it is in america if you look
at the map almost everybody who lives in
a big city votes democrat and everybody
who lives in between the big cities
what's republican i mean the maps are
incredible it's it's seas of red with
little dots of blue all over the country
we're really two different countries
right now
and we see the world entirely
differently and
if you travel in one circle you're not
going to run into a whole lot of trump
supporters i certainly don't um
and
again that that probably contributes to
why we didn't see it coming you know i
think most of the people who work in the
media
they're like me they live in new york la
and washington uh for the most part
um they
they like
shows like the wire and you know the
americans and you know they and they
watch movies with subtitles and they you
know eat ethnic food and rest and that's
how they you know they don't watch
nascar it's it's a cultural difference
so um
yeah and i think it's going to be very
tough for those two americans to
to
have any kind of
you know exchange with each other
did you have any friends or family
members that
were trump supporters that just shocked
you
well i do have i have some family
members who are trump supporters
but you know they've been conservatives
for for quite a long time so um i i
there are a couple of people who i know
who
who didn't vote
this time and that was a little bit
shocking
um
who and that
that i think spoke to
some frustration probably with the
democratic party um because these were
lifelong democrats who aren't voting
democratic anymore um
but
in terms of people who suddenly became
trump supporters no i don't know anybody
like that do you
this is an email from mancer johnson in
tucson arizona matt in your recent
article on goldman sachs purchase of
certificates issued by venezuela for 32
cents on the dollar you referred to
venezuelan president madeiro as a
dictator i was shocked you as a
progressive journalist would use the
word dictator the same characterization
of the venezuelan president that
elements in the u.s government have used
ever since chavez
yeah i heard some push back on that from
some people um
you know i i haven't lived in south
america i'm relying on people that i
know
who
cover south american politics and who
write to me from south america
you know my understanding of that
situation is
you know that he
essentially canceled elections and um
and has you know
has been acting in an un democratic way
uh but you know i i'll i i admit that
there's room for me to learn on that
that issue so i'll have to go back and
look
barry is calling in from scottsdale
arizona and barry you're on book tv with
matt taibi
hi matt how you doing
um how are you doing
good i'm doing great thanks for being on
this show uh two two questions a little
bit off the beaten path not really one
is
how did your thinking how did we get
from presidential candidate like gary
hart
thoughtful reflective
to donald trump
seems like a huge leap to me
secondly second question is
what's your take on president obama you
know i heard you say you voted for him i
voted for him too
but you know a number of problems we're
facing now
were allowed to fester under his
administration for eight years he really
didn't deal with them i mean there's
syria there's the racial divide in the
country which is
as bad as it's ever been
isis he was i don't know if he was
afraid to deal with them or whatever
what's your take i really liked him as a
human being but i just don't know as a
president if he really did anything
what's your take on those two issues
thank you i'll listen
no thanks uh well i wrote a piece about
obama right after the election and
you know i
i had been critical of barack obama in
the last eight years mainly because on
the subject
that i have covered throughout most of
his presidency which is corruption in
the financial services sector um
you know he he doesn't have a great
record there
his administration was mainly known for
uh not taking
not winning a single conviction against
any
senior level executive for any of the
corruption that led to the 2008
financial crisis and
so because that was my little bailiwick
you know i was i was critical of barack
obama i didn't like the fact that he
um
you know he ran as an economic
progressive
and then when he got elected he brought
in a whole bunch of people from
citigroup basically to run his
transition team and um you know people
like timothy geithner uh and eric holder
were
you know and lanny brewer who was the
assistant attorney general uh throughout
that time um
you know they they were corporate
lawyers who had
long worked for wall street they had all
the different all the banks had been
their clients and that came through in a
lot of their enforcement decisions and
so
just in in terms of that um i had always
been critical of obama but
you know upon reflection looking back at
him
um
i think history is going to look back on
him
in a very favorable way
not necessarily
because of
his policy ideas because as a
progressive person i think he was a
disappointment to a lot of a lot of
people um
in a lot of areas whether it's you know
the continuation of guantanamo bay or
the the drone bombings or whatever it
was um
but his his demeanor
uh his um
his
composure and his unwillingness to
to give in to
uh you know anger
and to not give up on um
whole segments of the society i was
really impressed by what he said after
the election
um and by way of i think criticizing
hillary clinton you know one of the
things he said was
you know i even in places where i knew i
was going to lose i continued to try to
reach
um
you know people in rural iowa and there
were places where i instead of losing by
50 points i only lost by 20 points and
and obama was what he was saying it
wasn't just a strategic thing that he
was talking about i thought he was
saying
basically you know we just can't give up
on being one whole country you know
he
he still tried no matter how bad the
abuse
directed toward him was and there was
you know just awful racist
horrible rhetoric you know including the
birther thing
he never
he never kind of took the bait and
and made it uh divisive and and uh and
vicious
and now when we have you know somebody
like trump as president where you know
every tiny slight becomes a twitter war
in 10 seconds um you know it's going to
impact the national character going
forward
for a whole generation and i think
obama's
the example he set for young people
about how to comport yourself i think
was a really important one even if i
didn't agree with a lot the things that
he did policy-wise so you know looking
back i i do i really admire barack obama
i think he um
he
acquitted himself incredibly well in
a nearly impossible situation uh despite
the fact that i was disappointed in some
of his decisions next call for matt
tybee comes from diana in lone pine
california hi diana
hi i'm so happy today
i get to speak to that
um
my first part is the comments
and um
i just want to say thank you for saying
that about roger ailes like i've been
watching this all this stuff back and
forth on various news channels for years
and
always the level of uh viciousness
it came from fox the level of fear i
watched it affect
my friends and i'm older and it was like
they just became so locked in that we
could we can't talk about anything like
that because i'm more of a liberal type
gal and my
and i just want to thank you for like uh
helping me with my thinking that i
wasn't going loony that one person can
affect a whole nation like that like day
after day year after year just spouting
such
his uh reporters just spouting such uh
mean stuff and most of the time
inaccurate
but um anyways you know the question i
want to ask you was
why do we need health insurance
companies like i've had
rounds with cancer and um luckily i've
had medicare and uh i live because of
that but why do i remember being as a
child we just went to the doctor
you know there wasn't any issue about uh
insurance
and so um
why do we need insurance companies that
take trillions of dollars
anyways thank you
yeah no thank you thank you for the um
yeah
it's been a while since i've covered
that subject but i mean i remember
[Music]
that
looking at the comparison of the costs
between
because america's health coverage is by
far
we have the most expensive health care
in the world compared to other
industrialized nations and the vast
majority of the money that we spend that
other countries don't spend
it goes to a couple of areas paperwork
and profit
those those are the biggest areas of
waste in the american health care system
and so you could you could solve the
paperwork problem
by having something like a single-payer
healthcare system where we at least had
some uniformity in billing
paperwork and collections you know right
now i remember visiting a hospital in
bayonne new jersey
and which i think subsequently shut down
where half of their administrative staff
was chasing collections uh and because
the they were dealing with so many
different health insurance companies and
they had to do so many so much
work just to get to the point where they
were trying to collect from the
different the different health insurers
um
that it it sapped all their uh their
bottom line
and they eventually went out of business
i believe and
that system just makes no sense to me
and of course you know profit in this
this area um
i understand that companies
have to make money for providing a
service but when you know half of the
money that we spend on health care is
profit that doesn't make sense to me
either so
um you know i'm it's not an area of
expertise for me but clearly the
american system
uh is the most irrational and illogical
one in the world and i agree with you i
mean i remember
one of the things i
enjoyed about russia is that when i got
sick i could just walk into a doctor's
office
and
you know the doctors there didn't have
the best equipment they didn't have the
best medicines always their shells are
sometimes empty but they you know they
would see me and um
and you know i think that that's
something that this generation is
growing up without this idea that
healthcare is something that you know
you have a right to and um i think
that's too bad
so yeah
in terms of roger ailes incidentally you
know i i agree with you i've had a lot
of people say the same things to me that
they lost family members over the years
because uh
you know their
fathers or mothers or their aunts or
uncles uh you know watched
the television all day long and became
increasingly angry and bitter uh and
unable to talk to
their friends and relatives anymore and
i think
um
the way we consume media now and i think
fox was the pioneer of this has made it
impossible for people with political
differences
to be friends
and that's that's really a shame i mean
when i grew up i mean i can't remember
it mattering what a person's political
opinions were and and now it means
everything and that's just a weird thing
it's really strange
did
the rolling stones john wenner assign
you the financial beat or did you ask to
cover that for many years um
so i i believe what happened with yon uh
and
so after the
the presidential election in 2008
because i had covered that
um
they assigned me it was was jan and my
editor at the time will dana uh they we
did one story and
they assigned one that was about aig if
i remember correctly uh and that was
very difficult for me because i had to
understand i didn't know anything so i'm
starting from zero i had to learn what a
collateralized debt obligation was or
you know
um or
cds's and all these things and um
and so that took me a long time but we
did it and we got such a huge response
to it because
you know financial media up until that
point had exclusively been written by
people who were catering to people in
the finance sector there is no financial
reporting for ordinary people and so
this idea of translating
for regular people
how wall street works it was a new thing
it had never been done before and so we
got such a response and we just kept
doing it and it turned into eight years
of work so it was
that was a really cool thing that was
it's but but jan
you know
he was great during that entire time i
don't think that there are many
editors who would allow reporters to do
8 000 word features about you know
subprime mortgage fraud or you know
how foreclosure works
these are really arcane difficult
labyrinthine
topics and they're not they don't sound
sexy uh and it's hard to sell
advertising probably to those to those
topics but he let me you know explore
them for a long long time
and
it was really it was great great stuff
and you you know i think that's that's
all you can ask for in an editor is that
they they support you in that way matt
tybee's most recent book is insane clown
president we have another hour and a
half to go in our program today and
chris in montague michigan you're on the
air
hi matt
i've been uh reading your articles in
rolling stone and i've seen some
similarities between your reporting and
hunter s thompson's in coverage of the
nixon campaign now just wondering if he
was an influence of yours or who some of
your other influences might be thanks
c-span
thanks that's chris right yeah yes chris
from michigan yeah um yeah thanks for
the question yeah clearly hunter
thompson was an influence of mine i
think every political reporter in the
country
you know grew up reading
uh
his books um actually one of the high
points of my entire career was that i
got to write the introduction to the
latest edition of fear and loathing on
the campaign trail um
that was a huge honor for me
i remember when
i was i think 15 years old my father and
another friend of mine we took a a road
trip from uh
from new york to key west and all we did
the whole way down was was read hunter
thompson aloud in the car
um i i love the way he wrote i thought
he was this weird four-dimensional
almost kind of writer and his he was so
funny and um
and he had his own language it wasn't
like dated he didn't write in 60s or 70s
language he kind of invented his own
strange language and
i i was really fascinated by him uh he
was an influence on me and
um
i i try not to copy him but it's really
hard not to you know especially since i
have his job uh and i'm covering the
same stuff that he was covering so it's
hard not to fall into those those
patterns but
um in terms of other reporters i you
know i i i grew up reading ichl menken
also uh he was somebody who i loved
reading
um
terry southern
uh
and then there were a lot of russians
who i read over the years who were who i
thought were great writers uh sergey
devlotto who was kind of like a reporter
he wrote wrote fiction but also they
were uh it was sort of journalism
um
but yeah in terms of that i mean there
are other writers who i read who weren't
journalists but of the journalists i
think those were the big ones did you
ever meet hunter s thomas i talked to
him on the phone once uh
so i got a sign
some a publishing company asked me to do
a um
a compilation like a uh it was supposed
to be a book um
about gonzo journalism so i was supposed
to put together a compilation of of
gonzo reporting
and i was young at the time and i you
know i kind of needed the money and i
started doing it and i chose a whole
bunch of uh articles and that i that i
thought uh
um kind of fit the tradition a little
bit but then i started to come up
against this problem that
really when you thought about it all
gonzo journalism meant was like hunter
thompson you know and um i thought i
can't really do this project without his
ascent and i also
you know i needed to know what he
thought about it so i called him up
and he said oh it sounds like a crappy
project and uh
i said yeah and he goes how badly do you
need the money and i said pretty badly
and he goes well i can't be part of it
but good luck to you you know and uh he
basically guilted me out of doing it so
um i didn't do it but uh but he was cool
you know and i i obviously since i've
met lots of people who knew him very
well and um and but he was nice to me
you know he took us took my call at
least
alexander sends in this email i found
insane clown president at the library
next to neil postman's among ourselves
to death i'm sorry amusing ourselves to
death which i was going to pick up
reading them together was quite
interesting was curious if you've ever
read amusing ourselves to death
if it was influential to you okay well
the second part of that question is
what are you currently reading matt and
any recommendations for the summer well
one of the things we do here on our
in-depth program is we ask our guests
for
what they are reading some of the books
that have influenced them and some of
their other influences and here are the
respect responses that matt taebe gave
us
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
matt tybee you list
a couple of books by evelyn waugh as
some of your favorites scoop and decline
and fall
who was he and
why is he on your list
he was a very funny british writer
satirist
i think his books
they have almost like a candide-like
quality to them they're really
they
they rush from scene to scene they're uh
like a lot of british writers there of
the
of that genre he has incredibly witty
dialogue you know it's sort of in the
oscar wilde uh you know noel coward kind
of vain
but i would i or graham greene was
another one of my favorite writers um
but uh what i love about evelyn was that
um
his books are just so beautifully
structured they're they're so incredibly
economical uh
he
um
you know every line is
is tight uh there's no wasted motion in
any of it and it's just
they're hilarious from start to finish
they make you think
um scoop which is
a book that every foreign correspondent
carries on his or her person uh you know
all over the world it's a great story
about a um
a guy who has a gardening column in uh
in a british newspaper
and uh he by accident gets dispatched to
cover a civil war in the in abyssinia in
the middle of africa
and because
it's it's like all comedies it's a
misunderstanding basically an
influential person
asks for somebody by that name and the
editor mistakenly thinks it's this
gardening columnist and so they send him
out to this brutal place and um
and it's just hilariously funny and and
uh
why
is uh he's like a great model for um
for
just satire in general because he has
this kind of panoramic view of
the entire absurdity of the human
experience and uh you know on top of
that just in terms of his um
craftsmanship he was just an incredibly
um
incredibly polished
uh
seamless kind of writer so he kind of
checks all the boxes for me have you
read anna karenina in
yeah that was one of the first books i
actually read in russian um
and
i know how that sounds because it's such
a big book but tolstoy
one of the great things about tolstoy uh
i can't believe i just said that that
sounds so pretentious but um
but uh
but tolstoy's uh writing
you know even in english even in
translation
it comes through that he he has this
incredible rare gift for the powerful
simple sentence right like he
he finds the absolute
simplest way to communicate the most
complicated thoughts uh and
that his his prose has this kind of
like uh
pulsating
uh
force you know that that kind of
picks up speed over time and and you
even in
even in russian he he
you know my russian
is good but not fantastic let's put it
that way but you know
he he uses simple words
um
and simple structure
uh in a way that is is just i think
gorgeous and it's interesting because i
also like some writers
some russian writers who have the
absolute the opposite
quality like uh gogol and dostoyevsky
they you know
they both dostoyevsky was a big fan of
goggles uh gogol is a fan of
these huge sprawling sentences and
paragraphs that are just crammed through
with subordinate clauses and it's like
really difficult to follow
and baroque uh
and but that but i like that style too
it's just you know there
there are two different ways of
achieving the same thing but um but
tolstoy is
uh you know just the simplicity is
amazing and beautiful and ingenious and
now you're a fan of footnotes using
footnotes in your work
footnotes yeah yeah and and again again
i grew up
i was way more a fan of the kind of
google method growing up which is that
is to have
huge long run-on sentences and
complications and subordinate clauses
and parentheses and and i i thought it
was a cool thing to
kind of force the the reader to
to do a little bit of work you know on
the way to
uh
getting to the point or to the punch
line or whatever it was and you know
footnotes and
and
you know taking various journeys on the
way to finishing
um
that was i i used to do that much more
now now i'm trying to go the other way
and make more simple declarative
sentences and you know
use fewer adverbs and subordinate
clauses and stuff like that on your
current reading list can't we disagree
more constructively by jonathan hate
yeah book about who is jonathan haye
he's a
i believe a professor here in new york
city um
and
this is just because i've been really
really depressed by
the state of american politics lately
and um
i just think the partisan
uh
nature of it has become
so angry and so like unredeeming you
know it and it's not it's the opposite
of uplifting you know like when i when i
read a political book i usually want to
feel better about life or at least
clearer you know and now most of the
time when i'm reading
political writing
it's just a bunch of people denouncing
another bunch of people and i've become
i've become interested in the idea of is
there is there another way is there
anything that's happier out there you
know and it's uh that was why i read
before this book i i read um
a book called utopia for realists by a
dutch writer
named rutger rucker bregman i think it's
his name
uh and it's just all about
you know
another
approach to politics that's vastly
different and why can't we have big
ideas anymore and
um and so
you know i'm reading jonathan it doesn't
necessarily mean that i agree with him
i'm just looking around for somebody
who's who's got a different approach to
politics and that that isn't just you
know blue versus red i'm just so tired
of that narrative you know
matt taibi is our guest on book tv here
is how you can contact us this afternoon
202 is the area code 748 8200 if you
live in the eastern central time zone
748-8201
for those of you in the mountain and
pacific time zones now throughout the
show we'll also put up our social media
addresses if you can't get through on
the phone line and still want to get a
comment or a question in
matt taibi is the author of seven books
his first one came out in 2000 and this
is called the exile sex drugs and libel
in the new russia
spanking the donkey came out in 2005
dispatches from the dumb season smells
like dead elephants dispatches from a
rotting empire in 2007.
i'm sorry spanking the donkey came out
in o5 the great derangement a terrifying
true story of war politics and religion
2009 griftopia story of bankers
politicians and the most audacious power
grab in american history came out in
2011 and the divide american injustice
in the age of the wealth gap 2014 and
insane clown president dispatches from
the 2016 circus
just came out this year
and
i want to ask you about something you
wrote in
the great derangement and of course i've
lost that piece of paper right now so
we'll have to
i see it right down here but if you can
explain what this is about
uh oh
i have a confession to make
it's not something that's easy to
explain but here goes
after two days of nearly constant
religious instruction
songs worship and praise
two days that for me meant an unending
regime of forced and fake
responses a funny thing started to
happen to my head
so
this was uh i was undercover right this
was a
i was trying to do
um
i guess it was a little bit of a spin on
like you know the kind of um
[Music]
like a black like me kind of a thing i
you know i i instead of
i sort of immersed myself in this
apocalyptic church down in texas and um
it was one of those mega churches where
they believe
the end of the world is coming
um
and you know they're rapturists
basically it was what they're called uh
the pastor is sort of a famous guy named
john hagee
he's a big
supporter of john mccain
and i was just interested in what that
mindset was like
and so in order to do that i had to
craft this persona and
join the church and i came up with this
alternative identity
and
i went away on retreats and learned all
the prayers and and did all the stuff
and um
and i think that's the section of the
book where i'm talking about how i
started to like it
after a while
and
um you know that was kind of
a key insight for me which was
that
it's there's a soothing
quality to all these rituals
um and you know the first time i walked
into the church and listened to the
music i thought this is the worst music
i've ever heard in my life but then
after
after about five weeks of this
you know i started to sing along with it
i was i was getting into it and by the
time i left it was it was getting to the
point where i i thought i have to get
out of here before you know
something happens to me permanently
so
um you know it was an interesting moment
i was trying to i was trying to explain
how
how people can fall for something
uh that on the outside seems ridiculous
uh but you know they they took people
who were vulnerable who were going
through difficult things in their lives
and they they
gave them answers and some of them were
simplistic but it provided comfort and i
was just trying to understand that
let's hear from marie in la mesa
california hi marie
hi thank you so much for
having book tv i've been a long time
follower and also a long time follower
of matt tybee
regarding that
the last thing that he addressed about
um
enjoying the the church that he was
going to a social psychologist speak to
that and of course marketers
know very well how the brain works
i'm 80 years old i'm
a volunteer with the k n s j and san
diego community radio
independent
non-commercial station and i was
wondering if matt
has a
suggestion
about community
radio
across the united states we provide an
alternative voice in san diego to what
we're hearing on
the news
constantly here
and
met you you said that we should
be seen as the truth in reporting news
and i'm wondering
uh
i'm wondering how as you go on your
speaking tours and you're talking about
the trump administration
uh trump himself
when we see a personal view of someone
who reports news
then
[Music]
for those who who read what that news
person writes
do we
do we see
can we see the truth
i mean
uh that's a good question um
you know the question of how do you get
at the truth what what like for instance
it's murray right i think marie so the
um
you know for community radio uh just to
answer that part of the question first
i've never worked in radio before but i
do think that um
that local media
is making a little bit of a comeback
and some of it is through internet based
media like podcasts
which have
taken ideas like cereal and they've done
it on
for their own and i think that's one
thing that's great
that community radio can do easily
and with relatively low cost is do
things like um
you know 12-part series about local
issues right so you can do
you know some local scandal or a crime
or
a trial
um
and it'll be interesting to your
listeners because they it's in their
neighborhood and it's about people they
know
but you you can use
uh storytelling techniques
um you know you don't have you can make
characters out of people i think that's
one of the cool things about the kind of
flowering of new medias as much as i've
been critical about the fracturing of it
we have
all these new
uh
innovations in form now that make it
really make we've found all these
different new interesting ways to tell
stories and to do the news so
if i were in community radio now i'd be
really excited about all the different
things that i could do you know
you could essentially make a kind of
rolling reality show about
about a local trial or um
i don't know even a local little league
team or anything you know
and
these
these are things that we wouldn't have
thought to do 40 or 50 years ago when
news was always
you know on the radio was four minute
broadcast of this or that or at the talk
show talk show um now you can do you
know sophisticated storytelling you can
do undercover things there's all kinds
of cool stuff you can do at radio so um
you know i would just try to be as
creative as possible with that and and
and take advantage of the fact that
you're local uh and that's the way to
compete with national uh
with national media you know you you
know the characters better than
nbc cbs and cnn know them uh so that's
that's an advantage that you have
uh in terms of of
trying to be truthful and can we ever
really know the truth i mean i i i
that's a huge metaphysical question but
what i would say is um
you know the best way to kind of arrive
at an understanding of what's going on
in the world for me is just to
consume as many different sources as
possible and and try to get at what the
common themes are you know like for
instance when
when i was trying to learn about wall
street
and i didn't know anything going into it
what i would do is i would call 20 or 30
people
and ask them the same question you know
what is a collateralized debt obligation
how does it work or uh you know what's
this what's a synthetic cdo and
and or what happened in with the lehman
bankruptcy and
you know i would get
30 stories and 25 of them would be
similar and you know
then you start to take the common
threads and that's
it's always an amalgamating process when
you're trying to figure out what's
actually going on you're never going to
get the whole unvarnished
uh truth from anybody but you know
that's what we do as human beings we got
to put it all together but
that's what being informed is all about
just read as much as possible
have you gotten into podcasts i mean
either listening or creating i i listen
to them and i may be starting a podcast
soon so um you know it's not it's not
quite ready to go but yeah i'm thinking
about doing that so i think it's a cool
it's a cool thing um it's a
it's a neat way of kind of communicating
with uh your audience and um
and it also allows you to do some
different stuff i mean you know the
what the work that i do
um it's pretty tough to do you know
comedy or anything that's or movie
reviews or book reviews it allows you to
kind of go into different directions
and i think it's neat i think there's a
lot of really interesting work going on
with that
next call eric is in middletown new york
eric you're on book tv with matt taibi
hi
good afternoon gentlemen nice to talk to
you both
uh matt i've got a uh a bit of a complex
one here for you um and i can touch on
just about every single thing that's
been been part of the discussion uh this
morning uh first off your dad was my
news guy along with johnny and sue
simmons for about the first 25 years of
my life
but um there you go
yeah yeah
you know i grew up on that stuff and i
spent many years in manhattan and
brooklyn as a funeral director i think i
spotted you a couple of times around the
nyu campus back around
six seven eight
so um in any problem i'm wondering yeah
i mean uh you got oh look to you um you
know and you're definitely your father's
son you guys a couple of handsome fellas
so in any event um i'm wondering you
know it's funny this last caller from uh
public or you know nonprofit
non-commercial radio um what a gal huh
80 years old still kicking tail
but uh in any any event um you mentioned
uh you guys were discussing the utility
of a thing like a trial and that's
something i'm dealing with and it
involves a corporate crime something you
touch down with the california welfare
case well they'll go after individual
benefit recipients but not these larger
companies that are just reaping these
these massive quantities of money i'm
wondering are you familiar with a case
in new york that's basically now in its
10th year it's been through the entire
appellate structure has created new law
and it's entitled landon the kroll it
involves criminal justice system drug
testing are you familiar with it at all
all right eric thank you very much matt
tybee uh no i i i'm not familiar with it
but i'm i'm interested in it uh can we
go on i'm curious what he is he is not
with us anymore um so you're gonna have
to do your own research on that case i
apologize um but you do
talk and i want to say it's from
griftopia
you talk about the fact that it's much
easier to
get a slam-dunk conviction but
not to take a case
a complex case to court that could last
10 20
years yeah no i i i heard this over and
over again from prosecutors
they said look look at it from our point
of view right like
we get evaluated according to how many
convictions we get so if you're us
are you going to go take hsbc to court
and they have the best lawyers in the
world and the standard of proof is is
it's not easy to meet you know or are we
going to take 50 drug dealers to court
and and get wins on all of them uh and
some of them you know we just throw them
in the box and we we scare them and they
confess you know uh
whereas with
these gigantic financial institutions
they don't admit a thing they dig in
they've got the best lawyers in the
world and even when they're plainly
guilty
it is extremely difficult to get
convictions i mean i i covered a trial
or it takes it takes so long that you
know
they sometimes can wait out the the
criminal justice system and force them
into mistakes because
they are trying to get within the
statute of limitations um i i covered a
case that involves
bid rigging in the municipal bond market
and they had these guys on tape and it
was they clearly clearly had them
but it took so long to get that case
through court among other things because
they had to educate the jury about all
the jargon uh and they had to defeat so
many emotions just to get there
that by the time they they you know they
went to trial they ended up losing some
of the defendants because they didn't
meet the 10-year
statute of limitations you know so
if you're a prosecutor
it is a difficult choice you're you're
going to take on these banks and you're
going to lose a lot of the time and and
but the problem is i i still think
symbolically you got to try because
otherwise what you're saying to the
people is
you know we're giving up right we we're
just gonna take the money from these
guys because it's too hard to take them
to trial so we'll we'll take the check
and then we're gonna put these people in
jail which invalidates jail as far as
i'm concerned you know that that that
makes it makes it uh
if you know if a certain class of people
can't go to jail and a certain only a
certain class of people can
then
that's that's not legitimate criminal
justice to me so you know i think you
got to try anyway
next call is rob in milford connecticut
rob please go ahead
uh matt as the only conservative who's
called in today i'm quite sure
peter i hope i can get my comment and
question out because as we consider to
see nationwide the left is very
intolerant of disagreeable voices
um
you talked earlier about not liking the
words liberal and conservative they're
shorthand
but you went to bard college which is an
extremely liberal college you work for a
man young winner who's an extremely
liberal man you've quoted h.l menkin and
hunter thompson saw hunter's picture on
the screen you've denigrated roger ailes
fox news
you've used the word conservative twice
you haven't used the word liberal
i understand what you said and i agree
there's no such thing as objectivity but
my comment is i think that you are as
partisan as fox news just on the other
side my question is to do with race
over the past 50 years by every single
metric all negative human behavior is
disproportionately occupied by black and
latino people
i contend that black and latino men
roughly between the ages of 15 and 40 15
and 45
have been and are today our greatest
domestic liability
eight trillion dollars have been spent
since 1965 the war on poverty matt
please answer this question i can't get
one liberal anywhere here at yale to
answer this is there any country in
sub-saharan africa or where spanish is
spoken whose standard of living is
comparable or greater than ours
matt tabi that was rob in milford
connecticut i don't even know where to
begin with with that question i mean
it's preposterous if you what you're
really saying is that you think that
there
that inherently
racially
black and hispanic people are more prone
to negative behavior than white people i
mean that that's what you're saying uh
with with that question uh
it's
it's absurd uh it's it's preposterous
and i think you should be ashamed of
yourself yeah if you wanna if you wanna
come after me and say i'm a liberal and
i'm an upper upper middle class
white kid who went to bard college and i
work for yon winter and you know you
don't see any difference between me and
fox news that's fine um even though i
clearly
regularly go after the democratic party
in my in my work
and uh i've never heard once fox news uh
to take on a conservative on that on
that station um you know i try to look
at everybody uh
and i i disagree with people
uh
you know of my own political character
all the time uh because i think that's
healthy uh it's not a business for me i
don't do this for for to try to scare
liberals into uh tuning into my
uh articles so that i can make money
this is about
trying to call things as i see them and
that's not what that's not what fox news
does and i think that your your
your views i couldn't disagree with them
more strongly and i'm i'm i feel sorry
for the that you feel that way
this is carolyn in spearfish south
dakota
matt how much blame should be this is an
email how much blame should belong to
the new york times in washington post
for so excoriating trump that the voters
went the other way in response
um i don't know about singling out those
two
publications
but i do think that that was a
phenomenon that was true
when we you know i talked about this in
my book that when when the reporters
went after trump
he rose in the polls he didn't go down
uh every single time he had one of those
scandals like for instance after
um
you know when he said i like people who
weren't captured about john mccain
you know the conventional wisdom among
the press corps was that's an
unsurvivable scandal right you know you
can maybe say things bad things about
mexicans in america but
about veterans come on i mean no no
politician has ever survived something
like that
and uh not only did he not go down in
the polls
when he was excoriated in the media he
he rose and then when he was confronted
about he denied that he ever said it and
the media went after him more and he
went up higher in the polls and i think
what we learned in that experience or we
should have learned
is that you know the huge section of the
public
uh
dislikes us more than they dislike
donald trump or and they distrust us
more than they distrust somebody like
donald trump
and this is why
i have a little bit of trouble with
people who say things like the media
didn't call out trump enough because we
we certainly did it was just that we
don't have any influence over a segment
of the population anymore um
and that's
you know i think we have to examine why
that is why why are we not listened to
by people out there
and i think some of it's a class thing
some of it's just that we are not
interested in
uh the same things that trump voters are
interested in but whatever it is we have
to we have to address it because that
was a problem from the 2009 book the
great derangement matt tayeby writes
washington politicians basically view
the people as a capricious and dangerous
enemy a dumb mob whose only interesting
quality happens to be in their power to
take away politicians jobs right yeah i
mean this is something i hear over and
over again from
people who work in congress and i've
heard of lots of stories from people who
tell who talk about how
the worst job in a senate office or a
house office is the person who has to
answer the constituent telephone calls
you know i hear stories about people who
sit there and when the phone rings they
just hold up hold it like this
you know politicians look at the voter
as a kind of
haranguing nuisance who um yeah i'm
talking generally there are obviously
exceptions that i've that i've run into
but for the most part
politics can be conducted without a
whole lot of interaction with the voter
basically you you construct a policy uh
that
is
that your donors support you get money
from your donors uh in exchange for
creating legislation that they like uh
then you do commercials you put the
commercials on air you do you do
appearances in the legacy media uh and
you run elections that way and most of
them are unoppo you know not seriously
opposed anyway so um
you know if if you play your cards right
you basically don't have to leave
washington in order to get reelected i
mean you can go you have to go home
symbolically to make a few appearances
but
the way the game is played now it's all
about raising money and doing
commercials and doing legacy media
appearances and you can do all of that
without really talking to people and i
think that's
that's a big problem with our politics
and interestingly sorry to trump
trump
differed from that trump based his
entire strategy on talking to people on
on the physically interacting with
people in all these small towns and it
was hugely successful
this is joe and this is an email
new york city
trump wants to repeal mccarran ferguson
act of 1944 allow insurance companies to
cross state lines you wrote that in
griftopia it did yeah i was really
i was really interested to hear i
remember hearing him talk about that the
for the for the first time
in new hampshire
he said it in a very strange way he kind
of
talked about insurance companies and
how they
in the lines it didn't quite make sense
at first but then i realized he was
talking about the anti-trust exemption
but i i haven't seen any evidence that
he
he wants to repeal the ant trust
exemption
enjoyed by health insurance companies um
so
it could turn out to be one of these
things that
you know trump talked about a lot of
things that he wanted to do
on the campaign trail but we're not
seeing having any evidence that he's
actually going to do them like you know
he wanted to end the
the um
the carried interest tax break you know
for people and who are
in private equity well you know where's
that proposal now you know that
so
um we'll see it was interesting hearing
him talk about it he and it was
one of many kind of populist themes that
he sounded as a candidate but
that seemed to work with people um
and uh
but you know again as president what is
he gonna carry through in any of it you
know we'll see i don't know i don't know
i wrote about this the other day i mean
he he um
a similar example was uh you know he was
in favor of drug uh importing uh drugs
from canada
um but we haven't seen any evidence that
he's really pushing for that either so
um you know same with barack obama same
with barack obama exactly
so this is this is again it's a problem
with american politics which is that
campaigns don't have a whole lot of
connection to reality they're just shows
and people tend to be much more
progressive or populist in their uh
as candidates than they are once they
get elected what would be the upside or
the downside in your view mr taibi of of
changing mccarran ferguson
well it would increase
competition between insurance insurance
companies um right now they don't have
to compete with each other uh and you
you
because of these the nh trust exemptions
they enjoy they basically have little
fiefdoms
and each state in each state yeah
exactly and it you know it was something
that they got
um
early on
uh you know i i guess it was in the
early 50s
that they got this exemption and they've
they've had it ever since and
um
it's one of the main reasons why health
insurance prices are so high uh
and the cost of health care is so high
and i
i think
you know
i also
favor you know other dif other
approaches to the healthcare problem
that would be more
you know less market-based maybe but but
if we're going to go a market-based
solution then i'd have we have to at
least
you know
make it more like a free market you know
right now it's essentially a big
protectionist racket where you know the
countries divvied up into little
territories and they get the charges
whatever they want within those
territories so
from insane clown president matt
tayeby's most recent book
voters in america not only aren't over
empowered they for decades now have been
almost totally disenfranchised
subjects of one of the more brilliant
change suppression
chained
pressing systems ever invented i'm going
to read that one more time because i
stumbled way too much
voters in america not only aren't
overempowered they've for decades now
been almost totally disenfranchised
subjects of one of the more brilliant
change suppressing systems ever invented
yeah and i think well all i was saying
is that
the
it's all the things that we've talked
about here today voters
they only they've only had two choices
for the most part
both of those
choices have tended to be supported by
the same
gigantic
corporate donors um
so
there's a weeding out process that has
been happening uh before people even get
to the point where they actually get to
make a political choice um
we essentially eliminate everybody who
doesn't have the ascent of the national
news media of the political donor class
and of the two
major political parties that that that
has been a triumvirate that has kind of
closely guarded the gates of power for
decades in this country
and
you know yes we get to choose between
one of two
parties that are acceptable to those
groups
but that's not a terribly uh wide amount
of political choice interestingly trump
kind of broke that mold you know he he
was a true outsider in a way uh he
didn't
need the money of the donor class to get
elected uh and he didn't need them
didn't use the media to get elected in
the traditional way
and he was an outsider to the republican
party so he didn't use their political
machinery um so there is a blueprint now
for somebody else to get elected
unfortunately when we finally had a real
political choice you know we i think
spent it on the wrong person but you
know it was interesting
next call for matt tybee comes from
linda in phoenix linda please go ahead
we're listening
uh yes great program
as always and i loved her
talking about the great russian
writers that we read in new york in the
public schools
in high school in the public schools but
my uh my question or comment is um
during the course of this whole program
um we've uh
the
the essence has been a very bleak
picture here in the united states
the polarization i go back my generation
is the vietnam war generation
and even then in the 60s we weren't as
polarized economically politically
culturally as we are today
it is
so
disturbing for people for persons of my
generation right now
um
we can't see this continuing on as it is
how can we continue on as a sovereign
nation with the government that is
inoperable
uh that that is uh growingly inoperable
and all we i can see is
um given history
the divisions the strong divisions and
an electorate where one in six persons
believes that democracy is not important
to them
um how can this not eventually erupt in
uh civil
unrest to the to to to to perhaps the
cause of spell eye
it's uh thank you linda
leave it there let's hear from matt
taibbi
yeah thanks linda
i i totally agree with you i'm i'm just
stressed about all the same things i
um
i think we're in an age
of
polarization that is
when we're going in a direction that's
unsustainable
i remember way back when i was writing
the great derangement or actually even
before that i did this i did a story
where i was like undercover working in
the
bush campaign in 2004 um and uh i
remember listening to people
and this was back then just about
republicans but um the thing that was
really interesting to me is that they
didn't have a vision of the country that
included
the
you know sort of
liberals that all they really wanted
their idea the the the sort of um
fantasy conception of the perfect
america was a world where just these
these uh liberal professors and actors
from hollywood and media figures they
just didn't exist anymore they didn't
want to they didn't want to get along
with them they just wanted them kind of
out of the way
and uh i thought well wow that's such a
negativistic vision of the country like
we have to have
a vision where everybody kind of finds a
way to get along and they don't have
that
now i see the same thing
going on with the other side i see
um
you know there's a new kind of politics
that i think has has come up in the last
year or so
where
it's not if you're a democrat sometimes
it's not about
here's what we stand for positively what
we're the the biggest thing that they're
about is is being against republicans
and they don't have a vision of the
country that includes
um you know republicans and look i i
understand the the the
there are frustrations people are angry
they believe that the republicans made a
racist choice um
they're misogynist and and um but you
know we have to live together ultimately
all of us and so there has to be
somebody has to come up with a way that
allows us all to talk to each other
again and um
i don't know what that is but i think
that's that's the magic formula going
forward is we have to have some kind of
national reconciliation and i i
i hope it's sooner rather than later
from insane clown president matt taibbi
writes that politics used to be a simple
predictable con
every four years the money men in dc
would team up with party hacks to throw
their weight behind whatever half bright
fraud of a candidate proved most adept
at snowing the population into buying a
warmed over version of the same crappy
policies they've always bought did 2016
change all that yeah definitely i i
think it did for the future too
possibly i mean
what what happened with trump and to a
lesser extent sanders
upset the apple cart maybe maybe forever
because the formula
has changed now
again in the old days in order to win
in order to in order to actually get to
the white house as opposed to just being
interesting and a factor like ross perot
in order to actually win you needed that
institutional support of the party uh
the money and the press now
you know what what trump and and sanders
both showed is that the voting public is
it has a way of thinking for itself now
that doesn't include this sort of
institutional uh you know bureaucratic
structure
um
and so it's not as simple a matter of as
a as a bunch of people with money
getting together with the party elders
and deciding who's going to be the
salesman who's going to who's going to
sell the polit the policies to the
people now we you know it's it's a uh
a bit of a an open season you know the
there anybody who
anybody can run anybody can win and you
know in trump in the case of trump that
turned out to be a negative but it's
interesting at least you know it's
opened up the the range of possibilities
how long did it take you to write a
paragraph like that that we just rest
oh i don't know i you know i
i
i i write fairly quickly i guess um
but i i
obsess i think that writers do it
different ways you know i heard
i read philip roth once that he
something about the way he writes that
he writes like 500 words a day or
something like this and i may be
missing who this was about but the whole
point was to
you know that they would think get the
sentence correct ahead of time and then
and then commit it to paper and you know
handwritten i i put text down uh pretty
quickly but then i sort of obsessively
go back and and play with it until it's
smaller and and tighter and so it's it's
everybody does it a different way
campaigns needed people only as props
matt taybee writes if a candidate wanted
to show that he or she was with it on
racial issues that candidate would visit
a predominantly black high school and be
photographed clapping to a school band
performance
if he wanted a worker friendly image
he'd visit a robotics factory in
wisconsin and be photographed wearing a
hard hat and goggles and so on right
yeah and again this is just the same
thing that i was talking about before
you don't really need people
to be a politician anymore you you need
them to be
props
for photo ops
but
to actually talk to them have their
support
you know that they had they had mastered
a way of of running elections that did
not necessarily involve the active and
you know the active participation of
voters
and they were able to do it through
you know money stagecraft production
values
all that stuff allowed them to bypass
you know the old school version of
politics where you had to actually go
into the union halls and and and or you
know elks club or whatever it was and
convince people um
no it's not done that way anymore you
know i think and trump incidentally this
pioneer
an even
more interesting way of running politics
was which is he didn't even have a
campaign he just was literally
a human being with a couple of
overheated ganglia behind his eyes
appearing on television and he just let
the entire media system be his campaign
structure and um you know he didn't even
he didn't even need staff let alone
people
to run his uh to run his campaign so
that was interesting too
and sometimes
his speeches would just be all riffs
wouldn't they they were almost all
entirely riffs
you know i talked to
my first boss in journalism was the uh
late wayne barrett uh who was a
investigative reporter here in um
at the village voice he died earlier
this year but he was one of trump's
first biographers and
i talked to wayne about trump and one of
the things he told me was that donald
trump had never in his life read a
prepared text until his father died
and he read something at his funeral
and so i watched out for that you know
and what what you would see on the
campaign trail with trump
was you would go to a place and
sometimes his campaign would distribute
a flyer that would have the prepared
remarks on it
and the first line would say something
like well so great to be back in
manchester and he would say it's so
great to be back in manchester and then
the second line on it was all it was all
like ad-libbed he couldn't
he's like constitutionally incapable of
sticking to a script although he did do
it for a brief period after after steve
bannon got hired which i thought was
interesting and that that period kind of
changed his campaign when he did this
bizarre thing about
about um reaching out to the
african-american voter uh and he
actually read those speeches you know
you could see it was almost he was
almost like a prisoner of war reading
you know but um
but for the most part he just gets up
there and riffs and uh yeah i think he
even he doesn't know what he's gonna say
most of the time
next call for matt tybee comes from
elizabeth in san marcos california
elizabeth please go ahead we're
listening
hi um
i love your work matt but
i called in to to mention that
obama never really gets credit for
landing the plane after the economy was
uh
headed off the cliff
and uh
you know then the then the the plane
landed on the oceans and everybody got
into the lifeboats and the republicans
refused to row you know so
with that as a backdrop i think it
really affected
obama's ability in his early days to get
a lot of things accomplished like
single-payer
given that our healthcare system was
like one-fifth of
the economy at that time you know all
these jobs
to eliminate those at that point would
have been catas you know catastrophic
but um
anyway i want to jump in on your media
thing and ask you a question
um
i don't think that trump
you know number one we have a now a
shattered media environment you know
trump sends out tweets and everybody is
chasing around like a laser pointer
and and big issues are not getting
addressed you know
everyone's running off to to talk about
some insane you know kofi or whatever
and the underlying issues that democracy
really demands a lot of uh
it's boring you know it's you know try
to get a hundred people in a room to
agree on anything and that's kind of
what our system is built on
and uh
but
would you agree that um
in our immediate environment today trump
really didn't do it alone i mean drive
time radio
is all conservative
other than npr and fox news is there
showing an alternate universe from what
you're seeing on cnn
and so the idea that cnn and msnbc
created trump i i don't necessarily buy
that you know given the number of men
that are driving around to have jobs as
drivers in this
this
country today you know that's who's
driving around in the middle of the
country they're listening to rush
limbaugh or ingram and
you know there's
so many conservative talkers
and they're no
very very few liberal talkers so anyway
could you comment on that a little bit
thank you that's elizabeth and san
marcos yeah elizabeth um
thanks just to quickly talk about the
first thing because i
that's a little bit um sort of near and
dear to my heart the whole issue of
barack obama and his response to the
financial crisis i remember
talking to
people on wall street
before obama took office
you know during the transition in 2008
when the you know the economy was in
full meltdown mode and clearly they were
they were still in the process of
constructing the bailouts
um and the bailouts were incidentally
almost a completely bipartisan effort
they
what obama and tim geithner did were
essentially the same things that that
george w bush and hank paulson started
while the economy began the tank in
september but beyond that i remember
talking to lots of people on wall street
and
you know not everybody had this view but
some people had this view
that
they were looking forward to barack
obama coming into office because
he was somebody who had
incredible communication skills and
would be able to get up in front of the
country
and explain what had happened with the
subprime mortgage crisis which was this
incredibly involved complicated
fraud that had essentially been
perpetrated on the markets
and had disproportionately targeted
you know sort of people of color and
lower income individuals and had led to
this massive foreclosure crisis
and obama
really didn't do that he he elected to
sort of not address the root causes of
the crisis in his response to it and he
did
he continued a policy that the
republicans started which was to
essentially throw a huge sum of money
um at the financial services sector uh
to allow him to get well again um and
they did and and it worked to a degree
uh but there were sort of persistent
structural problems that were left in
place
um that
laid the groundwork for i think future
problems in the markets so um yeah you
know i understand that he he inherited
an um unprecedented problem but
at least in the area of of the stuff
that i covered um you know i think he
was he was disappointing at least on on
that level because he was
he was somebody who could have sorted
out which was
something that was a very difficult
topic for the for the public and he
really just declined to do it you know
when he he did get a chance to talk
about in 60 minutes
one of the one of the few things that he
said was
some of the worst some of the least
ethical behavior on wall street wasn't
illegal
which is really lawyering i mean it's
true that doesn't mean that
other bad behavior on wall street wasn't
illegal it just means that some of it
wasn't illegal and he i think he he was
trying to split the baby in in a way
with that issue and and um you know that
was that was disappointing to me
um on the other issue about
you know trump not doing it alone well
the only thing i would say to that is
those you know dr afternoon radio and
fox and the daily caller and all those
things they've always been there uh and
and barack obama overcame them uh and he
won an election by 10 million votes in
2008. um i don't think those
those uh that the media landscape is not
uh
an insuperable obstacle to a skilled
politician i think what happened with
the trump phenomenon was there was a
perfect storm of a disaffected public um
a
candidate who was uniquely suited to
take take advantage of the kind of
reality show
format of the campaign coverage and then
there was a democratic uh
you know candidate that was kind of in
disarray and fed into a lot of the
rhetoric that that trump was was laying
out there so yeah i mean he had he had
all that media at his back but so of
other politicians and they've failed
back to insane clown president
trump supporters are people who are
tired of being told that they have to be
part of some kind of coalition in order
to have a political voice they
particularly hate being lectured about
alienating minorities especially by
members of their own party
yeah and this was um
this is something oddly enough that
david frum talked about in a uh in an
article for the atlantic uh you know
after mitt romney lost in 2012
the republicans kind of looked at what
at the results and said you know geez if
we just did a little bit better
with
hispanics
we'd probably have won that election and
so they started casting about for a
candidate who
would have like a softer message on
immigration uh and that and that was why
jeb bush ended up with a hundred million
dollars in in his you know
his campaign effort
early on in that race
but it turned out that the republican
electorate was in a completely different
place that that's not where they wanted
to go they didn't want to be a more
inclusive party they didn't want to be
more open-minded they didn't want to
welcome more people into the tent
they wanted what what donald trump was
selling which was something you know
very different in fact he wanted to
close the borders and send everybody
back and
um so i think the party was was out of
touch with its own electorate uh
and
you know
they were probably right in terms of
where the party should have gone but you
know it's a different matter to convince
people to go there
this is book tv on c-span 2 matt taibi
is our in-depth author guest this month
and matt is calling in from great
barrington massachusetts
hi mike how you doing
if i said mike i apologize that's his
father but go ahead matt no problem
i really appreciate the way you can slog
through really complicated stuff like
financial world
and come out and explain it and make it
clear there's another area that's very
complicated that no one touches on about
why we have an insane clown president
why there are so many insane things is
biology
there was a doctor homer in the early
80s
that proved
that the cause of all disease and mental
disease is caused by shocks to the
system this is all empirically proven
he's like snowden
living in norway they won't even let him
out at all
and uh i was wondering you seem like a
person that could actually slog through
russian
and financial [ __ ] and really get to the
bottom of it but no one brings up
biology there were animals doing all
this [ __ ]
all right we're going to leave it there
matt in great barrington massachusetts
and matt tybee here in new york any any
response for that
i don't know that that doctors work so i
don't think i could comment on it and
you know i'm not against doing medical
stories but um
that sounds like a big one to try to
tackle so i don't know you don't need to
comment if you don't want to this is an
email from marcellus
or from yeah from marcellus
two things why is sake h.h monroe one of
your favorite writers and why did you
leave intercept online website
um
well
i'll answer the second question first
because the less pleasant one um
so i was going to start up a publication
called uh or a website called racket
which was going to be part of the first
look
uh media
empire and um
you know what
all i can say is that it didn't work out
i had disagreements with management and
unfortunately that
that project never got off the ground it
was too bad we had a lot of really
talented cool people there and we we
were trying to recreate
i don't know if you remember spy
magazine
that we wanted to do something kind of
like that and um
and it just didn't work out
unfortunately was it a money issue no no
it was it was um
it was complicated it was sort of an
interpersonal thing i would say you know
a
clash of philosophies um
and uh
you know i i i just didn't and i may not
be the best boss in the world either so
uh you know i think that that that uh
that didn't work out but it's too it's
too bad but
they were really good people for the
most part um in terms of saki
saki is another
he's actually not very well known to
american audiences um
his writer named hector hugh monroe
uh
he's a little bit like wah uh you know
they're a little bit similar in style uh
saki was had a much darker
uh
blacker sense of humor um if i remember
correctly his mother was trampled to
death by a cow
so he
he um
he wrote a lot of short stories that
were
sort of um
famous for having
a very vicious
uh
you know there was often a a a a
a terrible animal in the story uh and
people were getting torn apart by pole
cats and things like that but he had a
very nasty dark view of
the sort of upper crust
uh
british aristocrats in the last phase of
the of the british empire uh and he was
a brilliant wordsmith um very screwed up
person personally uh but he um
he he wrote these gorgeous
incredibly funny stories um that were
really some of my favorites growing up i
actually named
my second son
his middle name is monroe after after
sake
and
i strongly advise anybody who's never
read sake stories to go do them because
they're they're really short
um you can read them you know in half an
hour but they're they're just brilliant
and so funny and it's too bad that he's
not
better known in the states have you had
any interaction at this point with the
trump white house have you called the
press office i have yeah you know i i've
i've
i've talked to some people in the trump
white house
um
not on the record though so you know i i
think um one of the things that that
happened
when this russia story started to break
is i i just
from my own curiosity i i tried to
figure out a lot of things so i've been
calling a lot of people in
in congress and senate
in the white house too um
trying to make sense of it but i haven't
gotten enough to be able to report on it
so unfortunately i don't have anything
that i can really contribute on well
eric levinson tweets in on russia there
are two stories that matt conflates
did russia interfere in the election
did trump collude with russia no that's
actually what i don't conflate
i've said from the beginning
that
and if you look back you'll see this in
the first stories that i wrote about
this that i wouldn't be surprised at all
if if russia was responsible for
the hack of the dnc um you know later
when donald trump himself said i think
it was probably russia i wrote about
that too i mean i i don't
i don't actually conflate those things i
think i think the problem is that people
do conflate them um
you know my my issue with the story is
okay let's say that that's true right um
that doesn't necessarily follow that
that trump and the russians colluded on
to do this
um
you know if you think about it from a
logical point of view there's no upside
for the russians to even involve trump
uh in in that caper if they if they
wanted to i mean
it
that's that's the problem that i have is
that
is people think that when i'm saying i
don't see proof of the collusion that
i'm saying that nothing happened i'm not
saying that i'm saying
i'm saying if you want to call someone a
traitor who's committed espionage
against the united states you need
something a little bit more solid than i
think so you know it's just not um
you know that that's
that's where i am with that
james in denham springs louisiana
dear sir whenever i read your rolling
stone articles about politicians and
their misconduct i get so mad that i
have to put down the magazine and get a
drink or take a walk around the block do
you get just as mad while you're writing
about them and their shenanigans
uh
yeah i mean
sometimes um
but you know the
writing about it is kind of the way you
you exercise that a little bit
um
again
part of the job is to get upset
so you know you try to find ways to make
sure that you're responding correctly to
something that's horrible you know i i
think it
um
if you're not getting upset you that
that's when you know that something's
going on and you're probably been doing
it for too long
phil portland oregon a few minutes left
with our guest matt taibi
well thank you c-span and uh hello matt
just a quick comment before my question
hi
a quick comment before my question and
that
this political system is quite
sustainable
as long as
profit from office political office
continues
the 90 answer to this profit from the
office term limits
now my question
you write about
the
wall street grabbing of pensions
does that involve public and private
and can it be stopped
can
they be controlled as i put too much
risk to our
public and private pensions
um i'll take my answer off the air thank
you
great thanks yeah well so i wrote a lot
about that in uh
in the last eight years um you know on a
couple of different levels one is
you know there's the whole question of
who's managing public pension funds um
and that's a that's a separate issue
there's a whole question of
are we paying exorbitant fees for hedge
funds that don't perform terribly well
to manage our money um you know i talked
to somebody who managed the a pension
fund in illinois uh and a public pension
fund and he said look you know i'm
paying like
you know
a few pennies to invest
the workers money in this gigantic index
fund
and it outperforms these hedge funds
that i'd have to pay tens of millions of
dollars to to manage
so why would i bother because over a
long period of time
and all pension funds are essentially
long-term investments
index funds are going to do just fine
for the most part
so this is that issue but the issue
that's more pertinent to the stuff that
i did
was
um
the fact that when we were
when these uh gigantic financial
companies were selling properties like
these toxic subprime mortgage
instruments uh they very often targeted
these big institutional investors like
pension funds because
what they would do is they would they
would take some state employee who
manages these funds who might make 75 or
100 000 and they'd take the person to
vegas or to the super bowl and hang out
with them for a week and
then that person next thing you know is
buying uh 20 million dollars worth of
some product and
what happened in the financial crisis is
that we saw losses of you know 25 30 35
percent across the board in these these
pension funds private and public because
they were buying huge masses of these
these um you know essentially worthless
uh subprime mortgage instruments it was
it was a snake oil game you know it's
the same thing as
people calling up your your grandparents
and and offering them
uh you know overpriced magazine
subscriptions uh you know you know you
have a vulnerable buyer and you just
sell them as much as you can of a
worthless product and that that's what
happened in the financial crisis that
was so
so um disturbing and so predatory and
sociopathic
but it wasn't terribly well explained to
the public and that that's one of the
things that i was trying to get at matt
tybee if somebody wanted to pick up one
of your books which one would you
recommend to them uh right now probably
the divide i think that's that's the one
that i'm you know happiest about um came
out in 2014 yeah uh the you know it's uh
i spent a lot of time reporting on that
book and i think it you know
there's
it was
it's the most elaborate of the books
that i've written but i have another one
coming out later this year that i'm that
i'm really excited about that's about
the eric garner case uh here in new york
um and
so i'm really looking forward to just
seeing how that that that one comes out
the divide
income inequality incarceration
inequality yeah two of the main topics
yeah basically you know i i had been
covering
white-collar crime uh for a long period
of time when i started writing this book
and at
after a period of time i i kept running
up against this issue of
man these guys are doing these
incredible scams and they're ripping off
enormous sums of money and they're and
some of them are brilliant they're
amazing crimes in their complexity but
they're not doing any time then even
when they get caught they never get
punished for it and so i
in order to
try to
bring out for readers how outrageous and
ridiculous that was i had to try to
understand how easy it was for other
people to go to jail and that was
something i didn't know a whole lot
about and so the divide is really kind
of this exploration where
i go to these various places and i talk
to people who have been imprisoned and
how they got to jail and how easy it is
for an ordinary person who just sort of
on the streets to end up end up you know
with a record whereas and i follow these
other cases that are
incredibly elaborate and destructive and
in the end nobody ends up having to pay
a single cent or do a time and do a day
in jail and it's it's a story that you
can't tell unless
it's a comparing contrast exercise and
so that's that's what this is it's kind
of this vast
uh exercise and sort of showing the two
different justice systems
lee is in rockville maryland and lee
you're on book tv good afternoon
uh good afternoon gentlemen uh really
great show today peter
um i
used to enjoy hearing you on imus in the
morning uh of course that's not on
anymore matt but uh anyway it was it was
used to you had you really had some good
banter with him
a lot a lot of good banter with him
i
you and i are old enough to remember
when the communist world was known as
the red menace
and
the
godless comedies things like that when
the cold war was going on and with good
reason now of course the country called
russia is run by a by a kgb thug by the
name of vladimir putin and he's cut out
of the same cloth they they still murder
people they still do all these the
terrible things all around the world
they they they support the genocidal
regime in syria they're they're not the
red menace anymore they're not the evil
empire that reagan used to call them but
they're a bunch of gangsters and thugs
yet
yet um we have a president who is
constantly singing the praises of of of
the russians he is national security
adviser initially flynn was in bed with
them his son-in-law is in bed with them
this is outrageous absolutely outrageous
i don't get it lee is that is that your
point that it's outrageous or did you
want to ask another question okay no
that's it that's outrageous
got it okay i mean uh look
i i was in russia when vladimir putin
became president
i wrote
long long
features about how horrible he was back
then i was i knew
i knew exactly who he was i knew where
he came from
i i was colleagues with people with
reporters who were subsequently
disappeared people like anna
politkovskaya and yuri shikachikan
people who are dead today um you know
because because they didn't get along
with the putin regime
you know no one is more sensitive than
me to the
the iniquity of vladimir putin's russia
um
my i
i'm totally aware of that
i just
i think that um
it's a little bit of a stretch though
to
to say that
let me just say that put it this way
four years ago barack when barack obama
was debating mitt romney on television
and romney said that russia was the
biggest threat facing the world
barack obama said the 80s want their
foreign policy back and he suggested
that look
russia is what it is but it's probably
better for us to to get along or find
some way to not be um completely hostile
enemies with them uh
than
than to go back to what it was in the
past
and um i think that um there's some
merit to that look we're two nuclear
powers
uh what happened in syria was an
incredibly dangerous thing uh when when
trump was lobbying lobbying missiles
into
into syria and there are russian forces
on the ground there i mean
you know that's that's a very very tense
situation that's that's the thing that i
worry about most of all with the trump
administration is nuclear war
and um
russia is what it is you know you don't
have to agree with it i don't i don't
like the regime there i've never liked
the regime there but we're probably
better off
not in a constant state of hostility
with russia than than we are uh in one
um at least that's my experience um and
you know of course if you ask russia
about
the russians about what their view of
americans is um they will have almost
exactly the same things to say about us
um for instance if you think about the
1996 election which i was also there for
uh in russia
we openly meddled in that election we
sent advisers to the boris yeltsin
campaign if you if you look at time time
magazine in july of 1996 there's a
picture of boris yeltsin and there's a
headline that says yanks to the rescue
uh because
we openly bragged about how we helped
him win reelection and the russians
still resent that stuff so there's
there's angst on both sides and yes it's
a terrible regime yes it's a third world
regime and they abuse journalists and
they and they crack down on all kinds of
freedoms and they support awful regimes
and that's who they are
but we're better off not at war with
them than we are without work with them
tyler in east lansing michigan home of
michigan state emails in i was pleased
to see you discussing jonathan hates
very important book the righteous mind
in that spirit
what do you see as conservatives best
point and what do you see as their
biggest shortcoming
the best point of conservatives yes and
their biggest shortcoming or a best
point
a shortcoming if that's easier rather
than putting you on the spot for the
best i mean i think the you know there's
a complaint out there
in conservative america that
um
you know that's certain that the liberal
mind and liberal media has become
more orthodox
and unaccepting of ideas
and more hostile
i don't know if that's true or not but i
think that
you know
from their point of view from
conservatives point of view what they
would say is
liberals run hollywood they run the
media they run campuses and we see our
world being taken over and that's why
we're so angry
and i'm not sure that
that um
you know that that it's a completely
invalid point of view i think i think
that there is some truth to the fact
that
that
you know the conservative point of view
is often excluded automatically
um
you know do i agree with it no but you
know i think that that it does happen um
but you know
in terms of their weakest point of view
just take that caller before who was
talking about how you know
the black and hispanic people are the
root of all evil i mean i think that
that kind of talk
um has become increasingly normalized in
uh especially the kind of fringe
conservative media and the stuff that
you see on a lot of those sites now is
um
is scary to me
frankly
a couple of facebook comments let's take
them in order this is harley
enjoyed you on imus i would like to know
if you think trump can really make a
difference in fighting global terror
bombings including the recent stuff
going on in england i don't think so i
think trump is uniquely unsuited to to
deal with the terrorism problem
i think it's a problem of enormous
complexity
it requires
it requires somebody who has
a
profound knowledge of all the different
relationships uh and historical
grievances of
in the region in in the middle east i
think you need to have somebody who
knows the difference between egypt and
yemen and
between the shiites and the sunnis and
you know and donald trump doesn't know
the difference between any of that stuff
it's just all one big area that needs to
be bombed to him you know and i think
that's been a failing of american
foreign policy is our unwillingness to
to kind of learn about what's going on
in that part of the world it was it was
a problem when we invaded
iraq frankly you know that we had this
incredibly simplistic idea that we were
going to go in there and the tanks were
going to roll and it was going to be
switzerland six weeks later um you know
and this great flowering of western
values was going to take place and that
and we did that because we had no idea
who these people were we weren't
interested in their point of view
and we didn't care about their history
their pride and their culture nothing
and um you know so
there are problems over there but we're
not going to solve it just by like
shaking our fists and dropping bombs on
it i don't think that works
joseph oppenheim posts on facebook matt
the world is the most peaceful
prosperous
healthy
etc this is coincided with the growth of
capitalism big banks multinational
companies etc thus aren't you naive to
think that the little guy is being
screwed
i don't know i mean why don't you ask
the little guy i mean i i would say that
incomes in this country have been the
real incomes have been declining
steadily since 1970 um you know the the
the
inequality uh has grown at an enormous
rate uh you know the the top 1 of the
country is making you know dozens of
times what it was making relative to the
rest of the country even 40 or 50 years
ago um
and
yes if you look at overall it at the
level of wealth in places like china you
might see a better standard of living
but in other parts of the world we've
seen
uh other phenomena that are that are
entirely negative like the growth of
inequality like the
the the the collapse of sovereign
nations in pla in in third world places
in in africa
um you know we've we've just seen less
order in the world in the last 30 or 40
years
so yeah and i understand that they're
that that uh global capitalism has
resulted in a lot of progress but there
are there are issues too and and
those underlie a lot of the frankly a
lot of the political grievances that are
going on in the states these days
sean and kaneohe hawaii we have one
minute left go ahead
aloha from hawaii almost cosmopolitan
state in the union
matt being hawaiian philippi have you
ever what's your favorite hawaiian in
filipino food and because you're a
rolling stone writer what's your
favorite album or ban
aloha mahalo
mahalo
um i like hollow hollow frankly
out of filipino food uh what is that
it's like this crazy ice cream-ish kind
of thing i don't even know how to
explain it
my wife's filipino also so we we eat uh
you know a little bit of filipino food
at home every now and then so um and
hawaiian food i don't know i've only
been to hawaii once so um you know i and
i've never met my relatives there as a
matter of fact so um
i'm ignorant as far as that goes uh
albums i have the worst musical taste in
the world and i'm too embarrassed to
share my musical uh preferences with
people uh on the air so uh
that's why they keep me away from music
at rolling stone and never never asked
me to write about it does it involve
disco or the bee gees or anything no i i
mean i like rap music a lot so um but i
like everything frankly it's just that
the you know i think if the ordinary
person heard what i listened to they
would think i was a real real geek or
more than they do now have you noticed
that your books over the years this came
out in the mid-aughts uh smells like
dead elephants your name is down there
at the bottom
but then this year
your name is
great big letters have you noticed that
at all that your name is growing
no yeah i i hadn't thought about that
that's that's cool though i guess right
yeah
all right for the last
three hours matt taibi has been our
guest on book tv's in-depth program very
quickly here's a list of his books
beginning with the exile which came out
in 2000 it's about sex drugs and libel
in the new russia spanking the donkeys
dispatches from the dumb season came out
after the o4 election smells like dead
elephants dispatches from a rotting
empire came out in 2007
the great derangement
came out in 2009 griftopia a story of
bankers politicians in the most
audacious power grab in american history
2011 the divide which mr tahibi
recommends as the book to pick up
amer uh american injustice in the age of
the wealth gap came out in 2014 and his
most recent book this year insane clown
president mr tabi thank you for your
time on booking peter thank you
i